Did you tell Goku that you love that?
>> No.
No.
Oh, no. No.
No. Aiden, no.
No. Help. And stop.
The leaks have to stop. They have to. Somebody has to Somebody
has to stop stabbing this guy in the back. Caesar has enough
daggers in his back. Hellbent,
please. It's It's the eyes of March in January.
Oh, she's evil. Oh my god, she's evil.
Oh my god, she's evil. What the
What the
Oh my god.
So, I'm going to catch people up super fast. All right. A couple
of the British commentary streamers, I say couple, uh, Aiden.
No, I up already. Dickers and Queen met up with Aiden. Aiden
said he's going to go to London for New Year's. All right. They
meet up for New Year's. They hang out a little bit. People, they
meet up. And Hellbent is also in the UK. Hellbent's like a chatter
mod in a couple of these communities. Artist does art assets
for Sunday. I think she did a lot of the Sunday art assets like
a especially a lot of the um
oh like the the 8bit style, you know, that that like pixelated
style, like pixel art. She does a lot of pixel art. So, she does
other art, too, but the pixel art stuff's particularly cool.
She was there and she kind of invited herself. Aiden really didn't
like that. Aiden had a long running feud with her. Okay. Aiden
doesn't like her.
Uh she also made all of Nick Duru's wiglers. Yes, true. Um Aiden
didn't like her. They hung out. He was a total [__]
to her. People defended Hellbent because Aiden was kind of being
a prick and miserable. And then Aiden crashed out for like two
days in a row on stream. Since then, I think this is almost what
this is almost a week ago that we started hearing about this
after New Year's Eve. And since then, it's been mostly radio
silence. Uh, a lot of them haven't even been streaming that much.
Okay. Can I see a picture of Aiden? Yeah. Hold on. Where's
If Riyle were here, I could just click on his profile. That's
Aiden.
That's Aiden. Okay, that's Aiden right there. Uh, okay. So, they
meet up. People are kind of with Aiden a little bit. Particularly
with Aiden.
Very evil. Very, very evil behavior. Okay.
They go a couple days, not a whole lot of noise. Then Purple
Perry Gaming here, Perry
Pepsi, some people call him still.
He flies over to London from
He's going to hang out with all these people and he's been doing
random [__] He went I think I saw videos of him rock
climbing with Hellbent. We showed that on the stream
like a couple streamers we know or that I know
have been hanging out IRL. I don't think they've been doing a
ton of content
and
it's turned into drama once again. Now this the the rumors I'm
hearing is apparently Perry got into some sort of argument or
something with Aiden or Aiden's community.
Allegations of doxing have arisen. Allegations of threatening
to Perry, of putting a hit out on Perry. Okay. All kinds of I
don't actually know, but all kinds of allegations about
>> and my understanding of what happens here, guys, >> is
that um >> Dickers and Aiden's stream getting drunk together
on wine.
like I guess uh goes into Icy and starts doxing Leo Convoy's
wife cuz he cuz he got so I think Dickers is still in the apartment
at this point. I don't think Dickers has spoken about this on
stream, guys. I I didn't uh No, I didn't see I didn't see that
happen. But basically, yeah. So, Aiden was drunk at Yeah, I think
what happened. So they end the stream that because now now Aiden
only really wants to hang out with Dickers cuz Dickers isn't
being too mean to him. And I guess Soul Soul doesn't he didn't
stream at all. Um but yeah, so Aiden Dickers are streaming. Aiden's
getting wine drunk and then after the stream they end it and
they um and Aiden goes into IC and basically like to show off
um
he's like posting about Leo Convoy's wife. Leo Convoy, if you
don't know, is this worthless loser. He's like filth. I'm not
going to sit here and defend art community. Um, and he's done
actually, you know, bad stuff over there, but basically Aiden
decides
>> Okay, hold on. Now, correct me if I'm wrong if you're
trying to do totally like totally unverifiable evil rumor mongering.
Don't people wasn't there like a fallout between Goat Katau and
Leo Convoy? Is this a thing that happened? Am I making this up?
I don't think I'm making this up. When I get these details, I
get them one time when I'm like trying to play video games and
I'm barely paying attention. Okay, so I think I was told this
in a like in a private VC at some point sometime. Okay, pretty
sure I was told this. And that basically this Leo convoy content
all sucks. And for some reason Aiden is hellbent,
for lack of a better phrase, uncovering this guy. Okay, hellbent
on covering this guy.
Has to cover this guy. Okay, now this go cattle person, random
woman in in uh Aiden's community, I think they stream part-time,
but that's just relevant context for why just I want you to think
about why Aiden would do like dog content for a long time about
um
dog content for a long time just beating up this one same guy
over and over again. Okay. >> To I guess show off to his
friends and I see by being like, "Oh, by the way, this is his
wife. Uh this is her name. This is where she live." I guess you
know stuff like that. I don't know the exact details. Is his
wife public? Well, that's the cope that certain characters will
come up with. All info was public. I'll explain it a bit. But
that's basically what happens is that Aiden I think he he's with
Yeah, he's with Dickers and he's in the hotel and he's like show
off to I He's like posting pictures of this like lady
this fat wife of Leos or whatever. Um I'm pretty So hold on.
I have some.
You really Aiden, by the way, actually before any of this happened,
I got banned from Icy because Aiden's like a [__]
and got mad that I didn't take a side in the Helvin Aiden argument.
I guess he said he said that I leaked the Helvin message. I don't
even I that was already public as far as I know. I thought Shove
made it public. I guess not. But I took the screenshot, but it
was already a public image.
>> She's um Oh, wait, wait, wait. So Aiden, I lot a lot
of these chat rooms have like you can't take screenshots and
show the logs on stream. That's how a lot of these chat rooms
work. Spicy's like that. Technically, I think you can kind of
be fine on spicy. If you're going to cover it on stream like
I I think it's like a weird line. If you're going to do Twitter,
you're supposed to engage with spicy. In fact, I think I covered
spicy stuff next like yesterday. I might I might have earned
a ban there technically under the rules. I think you're supposed
to actually be there and be willing to make those comments, but
I think Oh, wait. No, I went and talked to Chut about it. It's
probably fine.
Um, basically just don't dodge is the spicy rule. I don't know
what Icy is. Might be just don't screenshot anything.
Anyway, so Perry screenshotted something is what they're claiming
and they banned him for it >> or message. Anyway,
so I I had to I had to get this information secondhand, but I
guess Aiden uh had you know Aiden,
sorry guys, I I'm jumping. I I this this whole doxing stuff is
very disgusting to me. the way that Aiden obviously did it. You
could say he's drunk, but he goes on to justify it, but I'm dropping
the gun here and underplayed.
Let me just find the images I need, guys, on my phone. >> He's
finding the images he needs.
No, not like Transformers, like a YouTuber like this guy. >> Where's
the Where's the song? >> Oh, here it is. >> Okay.
Like a YouTuber. I think he used to be bigger. Yeah, he used
to do fairly big videos.
Um,
yeah. Just uh >> bunch of Sorry, I you know you're not
going to be able to read the
>> It looks like Was this guy um was this guy Becket before
it was cool? Is that who this guy is? He's like Becket before
it was cool to be Beckett.
Becket before he was cool.
Is that an accurate description of Leo Convoy? I just feel like
it looks like art community commentary
but um future Aiden maybe it looks like art community commentary
in a way I'd expect Becket to do
like just yeah that kind of thing
if just in case I'm I'm just showing you in case Aiden dies I
guess it happened this Aiden's justification at the time he says
um if you if you go after people's family I'll go after you your
family you policy okay that's true he didn't ban me after I leaked
that message he just 24-hour time me out And after I continued
arguing with him and he made a fool of himself on my stream,
then he banned me from ICE. That's true. He's >> dude,
no. Aiden should not call into any stream. Aiden Aiden needs
to go to sleep.
Aiden needs to
go to sleep. Okay, take a night off. You got to take a night
off, Aiden. >> Becoming Destiny. That's a That's a That's
a good point about what Aiden's doing. That is very true. He
does want a hog box. He is a loser to destroy and is being a
loser right now. Uh not no at least as far as I know. Um
anyway, so you know I don't really have like it was all deleted,
right? All the docs info was deleted. Not by Aiden, as far as
I know. I think it was moderators. I could be wrong. Um anyway,
so to recap,
wait, his moderators do the woman. You've been blaming it on
this guy the whole time. I guess it's pretty bad if if his moderators
do the woman and then Aiden was just like, "Oh, this is awesome.
I'm going to totally
>> uh do a stream together in hotel. Aiden gets wine drunk
and he starts posting this info. Now, apparently Soul I don't
have the messages, but apparently Soul starts like egging Aiden
on
>> to continue
posting like, "Oh, post this to Twitter, too. Post this to Twitter,
too." And um that's when Dickers, I guess, like
I don't have those as but it's like stuff like he both of them
but he basically says um he says what does he say about I the
thing I don't understand because I was in the VC guys is so
Dickers is in the room while Aiden's posting this but he's not
like protesting. I don't know I don't know I don't know exactly
how that went but I'm not I'm not saying even obviously Aiden's
the one to blame and I thought I thought Soul got a bit too much
blame compared to um compared to Aiden the one that's decided
to do this. Aiden was drunk. You know, when I'm drunk, I don't
dox people in order to show up to my [__] Hugbox
Discord like the [__] like a [__] loser.
So, I don't think that's a good enough justification at all.
At all. But anyway, um yeah, Soul says post apparently I I spoke
to Soul about this person said that um he said none of this is
bad yet. Okay, this is all like sorry, it's like bad depending
on what the docs was, depending on how public it was, depending
on how findable it was. Like none of this is like damning yet.
Oh, so Soul calls Aiden. He's like, "Oh, I'm taking you guys
to a crazy place." And um that was a nine. The reservation was
a nine. But so first we go to a Weather Spoon. We go to Weather
Spoons. Um
that this happened before. First we go to a Weather Spoons. If
you don't know Weather Spoons, it's an English pub chain. But
it's really I really like the atmosphere. I never went to like
a busy pub really. It was really awesome. Uh it was like cozy.
People seem to have a good time. The waitress was nice. Um staff
was friendly. We got a few years beers and um
Aiden oh they had a cool book >> and yeah we hang out there
a bit. Aiden starts talking about um >> Gokato how he loves
Goldkato. I thought this whole time it was a bit guys. This whole
time I thought it was a bit a comedy bit. This whole time >> I
thought it was a funny like an ironic bit and he wasn't really
in love with Goku. He is he is guys. He is um Aiden's love with
Gok.
It's very he was talking about apparently. So this is funny.
I guess Queenman got another um ace in the hole. Queen got another
ace in the hole, guys.
Because um on New Year's, Aiden got there 15 like 45 minutes
before New He got there late. >> Oh. Uh Aiden was in a
meeting, voice
before New Year's Aiden got there and Aiden said, "Sorry, I was
in a meeting." And Quimman said, "Oh, you were with Goat. You
were Goat."
And Queen had no reason to, you know, know that that was what
it was. that was the case. It turns out Queen was 100% right,
guys. On New Year's or New Year's Eve, Aiden before going to
the um
party at the boat
was in a call with Golkat. And not just that, guys.
The call was Aiden confessing his love to Golk. Aiden confessed
his love to Goat in a call on New Year's Eve. And not just that,
guys. She rejected him. Shoot.
Dude, there's
Okay,
Okay, if this were true,
the way this ends up getting out, okay, first of all, high level
of skepticism
because it's Perry. Okay, high level of skepticism because it's
Perry. But if it did get out, it would 100% be because Aiden
got drunk with Dickers alone
and thought he could talk to Dickers because Dickers is like
the normal nice person in the group,
not realizing Dickers is a total stone cold psychopath killer
and would absolutely
leak that information the second it became possible to do so.
Okay?
Like I that's that's just got to be the way this information
came out. If this information were true, I do have no reason
to believe it's completely true. I this specific
event happening, I don't know. I I feel like this is entirely
made up. Okay, we'll see. But if it were true, it would be entirely
on Dickers leaking it to the rest of that group. I think that's
my prediction. Okay, that's just my prediction. I don't know
that to be true. I've not gotten spoiler on that. All right,
that is just my prediction. rejected him. Aiden
on New Year's before meeting up with everybody goes on a call
with Gold Cat
and said that he likes her like that that he loves her and then
she and then she said that she didn't see him the same way is
my understanding of what happened. >> I It's painful to
hear. This is really up to make up about somebody. Okay, if Perry
is just making this up,
that's
nuts to make up about somebody. All >> it's a bit unclear,
guys. It's a bit unclear. Um my understanding is that um goat
said that she doesn't see him that way yet, something like that.
And that there was an insinuation that she might start to see
him that way or that she she saw him that way but not as much
as he did and that like you know she was like at a a less intense
feeling or she she wanted to take it slow. I think something
like that maybe. I don't think it was a full I don't think it
was a full um rejection guys. It was like um along the lines
of Aiden was like allin and Goka was interested but you know
tepidly
broaching the water.
That's a co. Well, you can come to your own conclusions if it's
a cope. If she's leading him on, >> if Aiden's friend zownzoned,
that's your And so, yeah, obviously Soul was giving advice about
how to pick up women. >> Um, it was good advice. It was
really good advice. Um,
Queen is leaking ice messages on stream. That's I can't see what's
happening on that streamer or
it's cuz I'm on my >> Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Is this Can I go to the lumpy Willy tweet at this point?
Am I ready? Am I a go for the lumpy Willy tweet? should like
my stream and subscribe to me and donate to me by the way. Um,
really bad timing. I didn't know we would go live. I Horrible,
horrible, horrible for >> I thought so. I thought so. Okay,
there's a lumpy Willy tweet that came out. Okay,
breaking news. After meeting up with alleged
Perry, Purple Perry
Okay. Uh, Aiden, exiled Aiden has been seen melting down after
Perry revealed Aiden allegedly being turned down by known streamer
Goat Kat Goat.
Very strange, bizarre stuff going down.
Wow. Okay, so this is I believe this would have to be Aiden.
Yes. Melting
Why am I supposed to be the life of the party and just be some
normal fun guy when I'm just bombarded with 50,000 distorted
rumors from a game of telephone as everyone runs to stream to
talk about the fact that I pee weirdly or some [__]
Wait, was there a story about him peeing?
Did I miss that?
Wait,
did I miss Now there is? Now there is. Yeah, like Yeah, I'm actually
glad, dude. He's got his own clavvicular story. Okay, the Mog
situation.
Uh, the tree mogging. All right.
Aiden
was mogged on this trip. Nothing worse.
Did he pull his pants down to his ankle? The Not as unlikely
as you might think given I believe. And again, this is totally
made up. I I've never verified this. I've been told Aiden was
homeschooled. Okay. If you if you go to homeschool, like if you're
homeschooled, that's a real risk, isn't it? I think it would
be anyway.
Like, yeah, I'm actually glad I didn't dance with these freaks
cuz some f slur would have probably had a cam sticking out of
his jacket to show to 100 viewers. I will remind everybody that
despite the self victimization here, I do believe it's Aiden
who leaks things first, I do believe Aiden is the first person
to go and start like
ranting about Hellbent in Icy Chat publicly, right? that everybody
else had kept kept like elements like any stories but the trip
private and then Aiden was the person who went to Icy Chat and
started like railing on hellbent right so oh it's so up that
these guys tell stories about me but is that really what is that
really the whole story is that it is that all of it keeps the
gloves on while he pick you guys are [__] uh you
want to talk about being spoiled like how the [__]
oh wait are these in order
46 after this you want to talk about being spoiled like how Do
you let someone else pay your tab without a thank you and just
run off immediately after? Lol. Did Perry do that to him? That's
that sounds like something Perry would do. I would listen. If
I was sitting if I went for dinner with Perry and he like went
to the bathroom and disappeared.
Okay. After five minutes, I'd be like that rascal. That
he just bounced. He stuck me with the check.
You know, I would I would I would just be like, you know what?
That was my bad. I went out for dinner with Perry. I knew that
was a risk. Knew that was a risk.
I knew that could have happened,
it just it just feels like I'm getting from all directions this
week. And it sucks cuz it's like banter mixed in with genuine
attempts to humiliate me. And now you have like like from Leo
space who legit have vested interest in watching my channel die
latch onto every gay little story and subdrama. And then on top
of that, people I actually open up to are just going scorch earth
on me for zero reason.
Is this actually true? Again, what why does Aiden when Aiden
is in the right when Aiden's like legitimately getting over?
Okay. Why does it have to be in the funniest way possible? It's
so I I don't I don't want to go out on this. I don't want to
go in on this guy. I've got no I've got no hate for Aiden. I've
got no reason to go in on Aiden.
And yet
whenever his when he's getting like objectively people are actually
kind of out to get him a little bit
it it's always in the funniest way such that I have to cover
it and it is hilarious and I have to laugh the whole time. It's
brutal, man. Uh I'm not saying this to sympathy bait because
yeah you are because this is like nothing in the grand scheme
of things. I'm just voicing my frustration so people understand
why I'm like an awkward uptype sometimes which probably came
out in my IRL interactions.
Uh yeah, this is like a
what do you call it? Uh post hawk, not post hawk. It's not logic,
but it's uh it's like
all of your behavior. Kind of weird.
>> Come on. >> So apparently
um Aiden and Soul go to club. They go to Lexington again and
um Hellbent I guess wants decides she wants to say hi to Soul
while he's in London.
You want to say hi to Soul. He's in London and she I was going
to say I didn't I don't interact with a lot of the other guys
like in this. I know like I've talked to these people on stream
but I don't do a lot of personal interactions.
Shout out to Quean for like kind of being a vault. Okay. Tell
Queman something. I I'm like I've talked to Queid about a lot
of different [__] that like now has come out like
when when when the whole thing with the um lawsuit came out.
I told Queid about um the Library of Congress thing like way
before that came out and was public before Ethan sued anybody.
I said Ethan's going to sue people. He's registering [__]
with the Library of Congress. Watch. It's going to happen 100%.
That never came out. Okay. I tell that to Perry. That comes out
like the next day.
I I can't even imagine. And now Perry somehow has information
on Soul Skippidity and Aiden's
interactions without him there. How the did he learn that,
No trusting any of these people. >> He goes to Lexington.
Say hi to Soul. Um Lexington is the club place, by the way. And
so she's at Lexington, too. And so is Soul and so is Aiden. But
as we've established, guys, Aiden and Hit don't like each other
very much. A and Hellbent don't like each other very
>> You know, I did mention the foot pain. I said my feet
hurt. Anyway, so
>> learned it from Hellbent. >> My understanding
is that Hellbent is basically trying to not be seen by Aiden
cuz she doesn't want I don't know him to get upset or whatever.
I guess you know it's too nice. What can I say? And but Soul
meets with her and you know, but she does eventually get spotted
by Aiden. Um, I guess before I get to this part of the story,
there's the fact that um there's the fact that um
what is it? Oh, Soul apparently got forcefully
um
kissed with tongue by a Mexican guy. Um there's also stuff about
how apparently Aiden
um got pity kissed by a lesbian cuz Soul told went up to this
lesbian he said looked like a bug.
>> don't don't say don't say Aiden is heartbroken or something.
>> Oh, this guy's never been kissed by a woman before and
apparently she made out with him. Um, so there's that, >> What
else?
>> what else? Wait, what? Oh, yeah. No, it's so um I mean
I don't I don't have the details. I wasn't there, but apparently
Soul was trying to pick up women the whole time. apparently.
I don't know if he managed, but uh he went up to a woman and
he he pointed to it and he's like, "Oh, that's my He's never
he's never actually kissed a woman
>> that's not even the first time he's dropped it in here.
He He already said Aiden was a kissless hugless virgin. That's
what That's what Perry >> I'm not sure if she thought she
he was gay or if she was lesbian, but then she she kissed him
with tongue and like, "Oh, so that's that's >> Everybody
Everybody wants to be Nick Fuentes, but nobody wants to pay the
price." Okay. Everybody wants the cult. Everybody wants the cult
of total sycopants who are 100% aligned to you. The incel cult,
okay? But nobody's willing to just not get laid or not try to
get laid. Nobody's willing to pay the iron price, okay? In seammen
retention,
nobody's willing to do it. That's why Nick won, okay?
Just retained all all of his essence, all of his ancient knowledge.
Okay? John Zurka would be >> His first kiss, guys. happened
yesterday. It happened yesterday about 24 hours ago. Wingman
sold. Seems that way. Seems that way. What else? What else was
I going to say? Oh. Oh, by the way, I forgot to say. Did you
notice Aiden wears makeup, guys? I went into Aiden's bathroom.
I saw that he has concealer. He wears concealer makeup for his
Why?
>> What is he doing? Dude, Perry's already dead. Perry's
already dead. Perry, stop. Perry. Perry. Perry. What the
dude?
What? I Dude,
Perry is trying to kill this guy. Actually, Perry is literally
trying to Dude, the funny thing is Perry's trying to kill this
guy after trying to kill this guy. Perry is like not Dude, he's
like
he can't believe Aiden has like no survival instinct, right?
Like Perry literally tried to kill this guy once and Hayden was
just like, "You know what? I'm going to come hang out again.
I'm I'm going to come hang out again." And Aiden's like, "Yeah,
let's hang out." Yeah, that's fine. No, what you did before that
was my fault actually. >> Exactly. Do you guys know that?
Isn't that crazy? Anyway, um it's such a pity kiss is worse than
I don't know if it was I don't know. I don't know if he knew
it was a pity kiss to be quite frank um at the time or now. I
I think I think so. I for sure told him. Anyway, so uh Hellbent
meets with um Soul and and Aiden sees her. So, wow. Aiden sees
at this club that he went to Hellb this woman that he has snarked
time and time again. Oh, she's such a son of Oh, it might be
for the dark s under his eyes. That's true. Clover cut the the
concealer. Um, so what is why is this >> Aiden powering
up like Goku when he sees >> mirror. So I can show it on
the street.
>> That's awesome. So
help Aiden sees Helman, this woman that he has been snarking
time and time again. And what happens guy? What happens? This
>> Harry says bathroom like an Indian guy. Bathroom. Bathroom.
Bathroom. Bathroom. We went through >> this. This happens.
>> Can you
Well, it's too small. Hold on. >> We have a stabilized
version of this somewhere. I need I need Somebody needs to get
on this stat. We had a stabilized version of this hell hellbent
logs. These hellbent logs. We got a stabilized
>> anybody? Anybody? Oh, >> I got >> I got
kicked from icy. Lol. I got kicked from icy. Is this what he
got banned for? Aiden's burning hatred to me. Blank blank. Uh,
you must have done something new, though. I was out last night
when when my friend's party was blank before or something before
realizing Aiden really doesn't want to see me. It was nearby,
so I stopped by. Aiden saw me and just I caught up with him and
was like, "Yo, we can go outside." He just shook his head without
looking at me. Wait, dude. He wasn't even joking. I thought he
was making this up. This seemed like another thing he made up,
okay, that Hellbent was like trying to hide from Aiden. She didn't
want to get seen by Aiden. It actually seems like she was actually
she was actually trying to hide and even more shockingly for
good reason that Aiden would like totally see and rage out the
second he saw her. >> Why? Aiden's burning hatred of me.
You must have said something new though. I was out last night
when my >> He like stormed out of the club, stopped just
outside the exit, pulled his phone out, banned her from Icy Chat,
and then walked back to his hotel or got an Uber back to his
hotel
And when my first party was over, I went to Lexington before
Aiden before realizing Aiden really doesn't want to see me cuz
Aiden was there. Um, it was nearby, so I stopped by. Aiden saw
me and just Sorry, it's cut off. And just bolted. Aiden saw me
and just >> Dude, I I already know exactly how Aiden would
defend those logs. Aiden would be like, "Uh, so like I guess
it's like wrong if I confront Hellb, if I just like leave, if
I just show that I don't want to be around her, and it's wrong
if I pretend it's okay to be around her. How do I even win?"
I feel like he would definitely do that. Okay. I feel like he'd
definitely say some [__] like that. I can't win either
way. You guys are going to criticize me either way.
Oh, you guys are evil. You guys are actually You guys are actually
evil. I don't so uncalled for
this. All of this was uncalled for. This was all uncalled for.
This is all up
>> You guys are sick. So Aiden sees Helvin at the club
that she went to to meet with Soul and he runs out. He literally
physically runs out. He physically runs out of the club. Now
it's a club so I assume it was more
somehow it took me like an hour and a half of watching this.
It took not even an hour and a half. It took like two hours of
watching this, okay, to realize that Perry showed up to this
stream with the specific explicit intention of ending Aiden's
like streaming career with this stream.
Like I I kind of knew he was just around, but now he's got like
multiple examples of Aiden's bad conduct to bring up to like
try to nuke this guy. He's like actually trying to go after this
guy's throat. It's pretty funny and a little crazy.
Now hold on. Teeny time. Tony says Mal is gonna cuck Aiden if
he hasn't already. Do we have any idea of Goat Kat's username
in Project Zomboid? Did we do we have Steam? Has Has she opened
up? Has she recently purchased recently logged into re recently
put hours into Project Zomboid? This is the real question. This
is the question we should all be asking. Can anybody check this?
Anybody? Anybody? Anybody who plays Zomboid with morale >> or
like he was like, you know,
speed walking, pushing past. It's a quite a packed club. Pushing
past, you know, all the people at the tables or whatever in order
to go out and there's no re-entry. So that's that's it. That's
it. He was done with the club as soon as Helen He saw Hel's there.
Done with the club. Done with the club. So let's see what else.
Oh, I'll just [__]
I want it to
Uh, can you see whatever, man? I'll read it. I caught up with
him and was like, "Yo, can we go outside and talk for two minutes?"
Right. So have a cat over. Yeah. And what does he say? What does
he say? He just
shook his head without looking at me.
Without looking at me. So >> don't imitate him. Don't imitate
him. He just shake. No eye contact, dude.
Oh my goodness. No eye contact. sees Helvin at the club dance
club goes outside. >> No, no, no. Please stop imit not
imitate him. No, no, Barry. No, no. >> Smoke. Oh, probably
in a smoke. And then Helen follows him. Can we just talk? And
he's like, >> "Don't no. >> We'll even make eye contact.
We'll even make eye contact
like like dude. Dude, this and that's the guy that's going to
sit here and pretend I'll talk
>> I I love I love compet. I look for right people. You
think I wouldn't say this to her face? You think I wouldn't say
this to her face? You think I just spent 5 hours in my icy hot
box saying this? I wouldn't say this to her face. Okay, sure,
Aiden. Sure, man. Sure, man. Yeah, you totally you totally would.
Kino Kino dog me. What the [__] is that? Scooby-Doo
noise. Well, if I had my full setup, I would play the Quean,
you're just free booting this. Pull up. Pull up Scooby-Doo running
sound effect. Quan, you're watching this. You're free booting
this. Pull up Scooby-Doo running sound effect.
>> Did Quan do this? Did he at least help the guy out?
pull up the Scooby-Doo running sound effect. >> Then send
me $100 anyway. Oh, my that reminds me uh when I met up with
Aiden for the >> Okay. Okay, that's the least you could
do. You could produce a little bit. >> The the cemetery,
the car cemetery. >> That's respectable.
he thought that we were we there's this there's a stop called
bank and there's a stop called Embankment and they're both different
routes on the line that we were on, the Nor line. and um he thought
that we were going to get to it and he was wrong. And and he
bet me $10. Aiden owes me €10.
Aiden owes me€ 10.
We made a€10 bet. Aiden needs to pay me $10 on stream. That was
the rules of the bets. If Aiden tries saying I paid for your
dinner, don't care. You said you would pay me $10 donation because
you were wrong about the
So, I'm waiting. I'm waiting. >> Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
>> I don't I don't know what that is. I don't know what
that I don't know what kino dog me is, guys. Um, sorry.
Yeah. So, he's just like he's like very very
mister. Oh, I'll
she's a dumb. It is the cuz like whenever Aiden was talking about
Hellbent when she wasn't there, he was like all filled with bluster
and oh, I I'll get her. He was doing that and then as soon as
Helvin showed up completely out sat on his ear buzz listen to
Beethoven and Kanye West sat in the club not dancing as soon
as
quick
um aura comparison.
Okay, you got you got Aiden here
kind of got to fit kind of got to fit. How could he ever hope
to match the Maltese meatball himself? Okay,
it's just not close. It's just not Some people say this photo
is edited. Obviously not. Obviously not edited at all. Okay.
Aiden Aiden has been mogged brutally. Aiden's been mogged brutally.
It's terrible. Terrible stuff. Okay.
>> Hell was up again. Runs away. He's a complete and total
coward. And don't let him ever pretend otherwise. Don't let him
ever pretend
>> Yeah. Okay. I get he's going to be back going back and
forth. He's >> talk about talk to him now. Well, yeah,
that was part of his rationale that it's like and he said this
several times. I don't know.
>> I don't know if it's like, "Hello, >> dude. You're
so You're so dumb. You're so dumb.
How can I be sharing her how could I be sharing Lia's wife's
work detail? You're If you're talking about the the um
>> I made that up." >> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa. Okay,
there's no way. >> Okay, chill the out, dude. Chill the
out cuz you've not mentioned this until now.
>> What? You've not mentioned this until now and you've
given me private information that corroborates that the bigger
contention cuz the main content >> you've given me other
information that corroborates that further. Aiden, this is not
the dub you think it is. >> That's not possible when I
made it up. I literally made it. That's not even real. >> Wait.
Okay. Already am I hearing like voice cracks? >> That's
not possible when I made it up. I literally made it. That's not
even real.
It's not even real.
Oh no. >> Okay, I'm not going to go into all of the details.
I've got my hand like
>> my [__] back now to like argue the particulars
in [__] public
>> dude. So from what I can see here and I don't know the
truth the truth or >> Yeah. the truthiness of any of these
statements. Okay.
Um, but Dickers is saying, "Hey,
like you've sent me further corroborating information on the
on the Texas thing. Why would you say that on stream?" And Aiden's
just like, "I made it up." And I think I think Dickers is like
I I think Dickers is a little concerned that Aiden is trying
to say he made it up somehow
as like some strategy,
but
that it is just a strategy and that Aiden's already proven it
to him that that's probably true.
little concerned about that. I don't know what the truth is.
Nobody got the truth is to be honest.
>> Really? Her name? >> Yeah, her face. >> Somebody
who's >> She doesn't work.
>> Yeah. So, unfortunately, >> cuz you not only leaked
you you've leaked both the name that she goes by
and her legal name.
>> Wait, I didn't I'm sorry. I didn't You shared it. Pardon
me, Aiden. You didn't originate the
>> I I think Aiden's really here in that he's built a community
where they do a lot of Leo convoy content
and like anti-loovoy content
and so him sharing private details in there, you're almost going
to at a base level enter the territory of harassment, right?
He can't really share a bunch of private information or even
like vaguely poorly connected
Kiwi Farms posted but not really publicly known private information.
He can't post that in his community that sirs Leo Convoy and
say, "Well, this isn't doxing
cuz it was public." Like, it's I'm sorry, your community hates
that guy, right? You've built a community that hates that guy.
You've shaped a community that hates that guy.
It's pretty crazy to say that posting all that stuff is totally
fine. somebody really long time ago.
>> Like if he was posting it in a totally different place,
it's possible there's some public interest or it's like they
don't know who that person is or there's some there's maybe some
excuse. But in his community, like just frankly imagine if I
did the same thing with Destiny, like posted um private details
of somebody close to him or something, right? That would obviously
be insane
and I wouldn't be able to get away with it by saying, "Oh, well,
it's all public." That would be crazy. >> Somebody a really
long time ago got doxed. I'm sorry for them. And now there's
like these like meme accounts that like post their stuff sometimes
and I like while drunk jokingly put their face uh in like a chat
and like uh use their name. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Do all those
years ago. I'm sorry. They were doxed all those years ago. >> You've
already taken the element. This is rough. Is Aiden hasn't been
drinking now, has he? >> I don't know why you're trying
to come in and like let's get this all again.
>> This is It's really hard to go into a place where somebody's
like totally calm, totally fine,
and to try to like
I don't know, fight them on something like this, right? It's
ah man
like he he shouldn't be doing this like for it's great content
for us. Holy, it's a bad decision for you. Why are you defending
it if you've already taken the >> There's no defense. Okay,
Dicker.
>> This is like Aiden making a conscious decision to give
Dickers like 30% of his audience for the next 6 months, maybe
50% of his like Aiden's like, I'm just going to go totally emotionally
compromised, possibly intoxicated,
and like double down on something I really shouldn't. I have
no business doubling down on. This is just asking somebody to
like take your audience. This is just asking somebody to like
literally just wearing the please me sign when you join this
VC. It's pretty >> like hit
if I hit some. No, no, I'm taking an L to something else. You
understand that you're I'm explaining
situation is wildly wrong. There was no work detail cuz I don't
know where she works cuz I didn't do any research into her. I
just looked up Lio Convoy's like Lio's wife and then the first
thing that you That's not true at all and I just >> Yeah,
exactly. You've been you were searching for a doc and that's
how you found it and it's a seven subscriber YouTube channel.
>> A public YouTube account.
>> Wait,
hold on. Did Aiden just come on here and go, "Oh, I'm going to
say that this is fake." Say what the the like specific private
information was. I'm going to say it's fake, but really what
he means is I didn't verify it. It's from a small account. So,
it might not be fake at all.
In fact, it seems like Dickers is concerned because it isn't
That That's what it seems like to me that Aiden's saying, "Well,
I didn't even look into it to see if it was real."
Okay, that doesn't make it
>> Well, okay. A publish,
>> bro. You can't be [__] serious right now.
It's got seven subscribers.
So the link's already been >> the videos that it's posting
are getting 10 views. >> This isn't doxing and this is
public. Wait, why didn't you contest my work? >> And and
he just came on this stream and said like one of the most like
probably one of the most publicly identifiable things that's
now I will say and I I don't hold dickers to this, okay? I don't
I've done this with people. I've refused people to come on my
stream before. If I'm like friends with them and they're having
like a meltdown like this, like I would I would I would move
them uh because I I've not done it before. And it's cat it's
catastrophic. Like you won't have a friendship with this person.
They will blame Aiden will blame Dickers for this. They he'll
he will think later like I was totally
this guy was my friend. He didn't help
Like but hey, we're all content people. So, for the sake of content,
this is really funny. I'm just saying that like if you're friends
with somebody, you should take them out in this situation cuz
I've not done it before. And it's always a mistake. It's always
It's always a mistake if you want to maintain >> working
definition of doxing like
when the camera is happening. >> I've got no idea about
your working definition of doxing. I I don't
>> Well, then let's establish a definition. Okay. Do you
believe this is doxing?
We need to we need to ground our definitions right now.
>> A brother. Oh, brother. Oh, brother. >> Spreading
dogs. If you want to be particular, sure. >> Okay. So,
do you think whenever you spread like somebody's name or face,
you believe that's spreading dogs.
>> Um, unless it's publicly available.
>> Unless they've shared it themselves.
>> Unless they've sh Okay, this person she she has shared
her name herself.
where uh >> she has a personal Facebook that somebody been
able to find. Is that what you're talking about? >> Cuz
don't forget, you're also connecting to this real the real life
identity of Leo Convoy. >> And despite the fact that you're
making these arguments to say that it's like completely innocent
and harmless, you said that you have argued that this is a way
to be able to pressure Leo Convoy into having conversation with
you. connection. All of these,
>> dude. There's no way Aiden was like, she posted this
herself on her personal Facebook page. There's no shot. There's
no shot,
dude. And he came in here so hot, willing to like publicly have
this.
This is real bad. Oh, this is so much worse than I thought. Aiden,
if you're watching right now, go to bed. Aiden, if you're watching
right now, go to bed. Go to bed. I don't think he's watching.
If anything, he'd be watching Moral because he knows that Moral's
in those Goat DMs right now. Okay, he knows for a fact that that's
going on right now. But Aiden, if on the off chance Aiden, you're
watching, just go to bed.
Time to stop the bleeding. Okay, >> arguments over the
fact that it's like totally minimal and totally innocent. It's
not going to cause any harm. We've already hashed this out in
private, >> dicker, because you're wrong. There's no I
just realized it's not because there's actually no docs to begin
with. I've actually just realized you're like completely wrong.
Who who >> you're taking back? You taking the L. You're
now standing on the >> No, no, no. I'm saying you're like
getting like fun.
>> Can Can I just get Can I get a specific about what you're
taking the L on here cuz it sounds like you're defending
>> Hold on. Hold on. I actually kind of understand why
Dickers is annoyed cuz from what I heard,
somebody was telling me that Dickers literally had this conversation
with Aiden in a VC already. And like he had it offstream like
he had the combo offstream and tried to set Aiden straight and
then Aiden wants to come back on stream after losing. He resets.
Okay. He resets. He's back on stream trying to fight it again.
>> No. Okay. So, I think you're having this like neurotic
like uh complete overexaggeration to me shar. >> I'm sure
I'm sure I'm the one that sounds neurotic is linking a private
anonymous online identity, right? are linking one's private online
identity to their personally to personally identifiable information.
The problem we run into here is that there is no separation between
Thomas Squa and Lio Convoy as I >> goes under his full
name. He announces his full name and calls and he's announced
his wife's full name and what she does for an occupation. There
is no >> Can you show me evidence for that? You never brought
this up when we first had this argument. He was public. If he
was public about
>> Oh, is this like Aiden went through and Filmont searched
Lio's like
history or something? Like his his YouTube channel, found a clip
found a clip of of Lio like talking about his wife's wife >> Why
is Why is everybody in Discord calling him calling her Lio's
wife?
>> Wait, he's he's literally said my wife. My wife. I don't
remember. >> Okay, dude. You're not going to be coming
on my stream giving information. You can give it in specifics.
I'm not going to [__] have this on my screen. I don't
know what I don't know why you're trying to do this. >> I'm
explaining >> legit. You can literally just use a
>> There's no docs.
>> Okay. I'm >> Yeah, that's the entire contention.
Dickers literally disagrees with you. Dickers literally says,
"No, you are doxing this person." That's his entire point. You're
on his stream. Obviously, you can't just dox some random person
on his stream. Obviously, he'd be and you're like, "No, it's
not doxing because it's public. Here, let me say the name a hundred
times."
He's like just rattling. Dude, stop. Like, just stop.
I'm telling you that I'm uncomfortable having this on my stream.
Don't say this woman's name. Don't say this woman's pretending
that don't post me a picture like this woman's face. You've already
taken a [__] L. >> You're pretending that something's
a doc and getting offended. We're arguing right now. I am saying
that I'm uncomfortable having it on my platform. So, chill the
out. Stop leaking these people's names. This is not widely circulated.
If this was already private or if this was already publicly circulated,
why would you have
a log YouTube accounts trying to publicize this information further?
Why did you argue to me that leaking this information was a way
to be able to strongarm Lio into having a conversation with you?
You said this to me in private. You repeated it to Queman that
if Leo doesn't want his wife's information out there, he should
have an argument with you. >> Do you understand that was
>> wait say that again was a way to be able to strongarm
Lio into having a conversation with you? You said this to me
in the log YouTube account. This was already publicly circulated.
Why would you have
a log YouTube accounts trying to publicize this information further?
Why did you argue to me that leaking this information was a way
to be able to strongarm Lio into having a conversation with you?
You said this to me in private. You repeated it to Quean that
if Lo doesn't want his wife's information out there, he should
have an argument with you. >> Do you understand that was
a
Wait, so your argument is so sh. Also, by the way, I love that
we've abandoned the leaking point and we've also abandoned the
doxing point now that we realized there was no separation between
the >> No, we haven't.
>> Dude, dude,
this is again this is like ego, right? This is like just ego.
He like he thinks he can he can make it right. This is I hate
to just say the thing that's obvious to everybody. This guy watched
too many Destiny VODs when he was growing up. He's like, "Oh,
I can go I can go and win. I can win the debate right now." And
it's like, "Dude,
I'm sorry. You're not You're not the same. You're not built like
that, Aiden. I'm sorry, man.
Let's debate it." Okay. Do you believe that doxing has to involve
a separate do you believe that one's private online identity
uh >> well this is gonna this is obviously going to be
a parallel breaker given that this is somebody's wife this is
somebody without a anonymous public identity but go ahead >> yeah
so and so how is she >> so obviously the definition that
you're trying to lay out there will definitionally not apply
let's say par's girlfriend let's say your family members they
don't have a private online persona so leaking their information
and tying it to you even if you choose to share share your full
name. That is also
>> No. Who would the only victim of doxing in this instance
would have been you could argue liar's the victim of doxing if
I'm vote if I'm connecting the family member to him? >> What?
And she's not. >> You can't dox someone who doesn't have
an anick.
>> If you pulled information about her occupation and she's
the person who gets harassed.
Yes.
Yes. Like obviously
who are they going to harass with her occupation information?
Possibly something about where she works specifically and her
name. Who's going to get harassed? Aiden. Who's the person who
is going to be the victim of the thing? The doxing was done in
service of the harassment.
Her. Obviously >> you're connecting him. >> It's
like it's like so dude that's that's how you know how lost he
is. He can't even he can't even he he doesn't get it. He literally
doesn't get the primary point.
>> What is the utility of sharing this >> Dick now
we're you can't just >> Yeah. Okay. Dickers gets it. Yeah.
Dickers gets it. It's pretty obvious, >> I'm saying the
utility of sharing this information is that you should not know
this information. >> It's edgy. You're affirming and it
is personally identifiable information. >> YouTube screenshots.
>> Okay. Is he he's not arguing. This must have been a
group chat and not icy chat, right? like his his pseudo public
chat that you only have to be in his discord for like a couple
days to get into.
There's no possible way that he is saying it was private because
I posted in a discord that you have to be in for like a week
and a half tops to get into. That would be crazy. >> So,
you taken the L the other night. You've completely rescinded
that now. I'm still waiting to hear what you still take the L
on cuz apparently it's >> This is bizarre. Somebody posted
there. I just looked something up on YouTube post a screenshot
some chat and you're like how? No, that's not true. That's not
true at all. It's not It's not impulsive at all. You have it
saved in your phone gallery. You were showing me on YouTube.
You apparently had this in your phone gallery for it weeks. Wait.
No. No. >> Okay. So, now you've just lied because if people
rewind the stream by 5 minutes, I said I searched up on YouTube,
saw the account, and screenshotted it. >> Yeah. And then
sent it into the public >> Yeah. So, what string of events
had this in your phone gallery? Yeah. Because that's how a [__]
>> Well, he's saying you had it in your phone gallery.
>> Screenshot works. >> Yeah, but you're making out
to sound impulsive. It's not impulsive at all. >> That's
the only thing that I'm taking issue with FYI. And you're spuring
out over this minor point. >> Bickers, how do you screenshot
something without having it in your phone gallery? >> You
can't engage with the facts, which are that he's a doctor. Unfortunately,
>> not under any definition we've used.
>> There is. Okay. >> It's actually It's okay because
Aiden's in the right. Have you considered that? >> Did
you just say Aiden doc? No. No. It's not cuz it's in the right.
It's cuz your argument doesn't hold up. You can't do the sarcastic.
Oh, you're never wrong when your entire basis for defending this
until this point is that does this to other people. >> You
could do the I'm not doing anything after you.
>> I'm not doing anything. I'm addressing the other guy
that's in the cult. That's who I was talking to. >> Okay.
So you can't do like your like I like to do performative victory
labs and arguments too like Yeah. D
we're talking about the fact that
this is really the topic of
>> Yeah. I'm saying this is completely derailed topic dude.
Your defense the entire time has been that deserves this because
he does it to other people.
>> Okay. But I'm saying your entire argument all along
is >> I'm trying I'm trying to I Dude, I'm up the timing
so badly. I'm trying to make it so that when Perry talks, I go
to Perry. When Aiden talks, I go to Aiden. And then back to Dickers
when Dickers is talking. Okay. But I'm the timing so >> It's
on YouTube. It's already publicly available. That's been one
argument that it's already public. And then other arguments you've
made is that deserves to be doxed or's wife deserves to be doxed
because of what he does. That's been your argument the entire
time. That has been your core argument. How many times have you
told me you don't understand what this guy is. You don't understand
how bad this guy is. I'm gonna make a vi a video about liio convoy
and you know what you're gonna say afterwards sickers I get it
I get it
>> yeah what does that have to do with anything why >> your
justification so far is that for other reasons it's been totally
okay or that actually liar was open himself >> even this
scenario where nobody that nobody has been dogs nobody's been
dogs
>> sure you said >> I'm guessing it was publicly
available information like convoy's wife's face name occupation
you just you my definition of doxing of connecting personally
identifiable information to a public uh to or >> I'm saying
that it's insufficient.
>> Yeah, that's that's not even the primary definition
most people use for doxing. That is one part that is one way
you could publish that information. That's one way you could
connect like you could connect an online identity to publicly
available information.
Um, but doxing by itself is just collecting personally identifiable
information and publishing it for the purpose of harassment.
Right?
Now, one way you could do that is by connecting that publicly
identifiable information to a pseudo anonymous like identifier
online. Another way you could do it is just have people who believe
you who are like you're you're like, "Oh, this is somebody bad.
Here's information on them." Right? It could just be or or it
could be somebody publicly known like hey here's this here's
Elon Musk's address right could be like an example
here I I found Elon Musk's address here it is right there's many
kinds of doxing this is one of those things where you're doing
both the person is important because they're attached to Leo
convoy convoy that's why they're important to you but you are
in fact just publishing their information in a place where it
is possible people are at a much higher proclivity much higher
likelihood of harassing this person you are you have a community
that is explicitly built for that. Uh, what was the point of
finding his wife's name and posting it? It sounds like, from
what I'm hearing, it sounds to me a little bit
like Aiden told both Dickers and Queen that he was looking this
stuff up and he was going to he was going to post this stuff
in his little private chat to pressure convoy into having a conversation
with them. >> Okay. So, so you think that the you think
the definition of connecting personally identifiable information
to a private online uh persona, you would disagree with that?
>> It's insufficient. Yes,
>> because she doesn't have a public online
>> Uh, just give the Elon she's the wife of somebody with
a public online persona. >> Dickers, stickers. I'm trying
to establish a standard definition so we could work because then
we would work in this argument why this does or does not fit
the standard definition. So, I'm not asking for a contextually
specific definition. I'm saying in general, >> I'm not
giving you a contextually specific definition. saying you need
to remember you need
>> what why is Aiden acting like he doesn't know the collecting
like finding
um personally identifiable information which you publish for
the purpose of harassment right it can't it could be publicly
like it could be publicly available information you might have
some element of previously unknown or somewhat obiscated there's
like different ways you can like you can qualify the the p the
private information. But usually like even if you just even if
you could look up somebody's name and address like pretty easily,
right? If you collected all of that and put in a place that you
knew hated them and said like here here's all this stuff, >> these
guys, right? That's still probably
>> probably gets a little gets a little there. But
>> think he's probably drunken on aderall. Are you sure
he's not drunken on like Mitch Jones? Maybe he's drunken on.
Do you think about that? Yeah. >> Can you define >> obviously
you need to include the fact this covers other people's family
members as well.
>> Okay. So that would Okay. So the personal information
>> if I get all your information all of Goat's information
or your dad's information and then I never publicize yours obviously
that's what dickers under the so under the the reason you would
establish a standard. Okay. So the standard definition that I
just laid out let me explain.
I kind of if do I go try to find the Queen andbod? I just want
to see him chimp out about the definition because I know Queen
is going to get really annoyed that they can't go to the standard
definition that everyone uses that Aiden's providing like a weird
definition that Dickers is saying is insufficient, but just give
the one everybody knows.
Just give give the one everybody knows. Yeah. No, sorry. I know.
I just want to see cuz I'm like, dude, he's going to be chipping
out that they can't figure out the like the definition is well
known. I guarantee you you're going to hear Quimman like clicketity
clacketing on his keyboard getting frustrated that Dickers isn't
saying what the definition is. Oh, I don't have a transcript
here. What the >> whis doesn't have a transcript yet? >> to
you why the supposed like reason the reason you just provided
as to why that definition isn't sufficient actually uh is is
inaccurate. When we're talking about somebody's family members
in relation to the anonymous online persona, the family members
talking about the that counts as the personally identifying information
that would still fall under the standard definition as I've provided
it. So if you
Yeah, I dude the standard definition not including hey I I found
Elon Musk's address. I'm going to publish that online so people
harass him. I'm gonna publish that online and say, "Sure, it
would be bad if anything happened to Elon Musk." And apparently
that's not to doxic according to Aiden. >> You have a issue
with my standard.
>> I might be I might be doxing Elon Musk's like stepdaughter,
trans stepdaughter who plays League of Legends under some pseudonymous
account. Okay. >> In addition to docing I would then you
should probably rephrase cuz the what you just said >> I
have I've already said that it's
>> Yeah. And I've just explained to you why your why your
premise for why it would be insufficient uh is not uh >> cuz
I've said that it obviously covers people's family members. Do
you think that the stuff that Ben and Panata shared about Willie
Mac's wife was a
>> I have no idea. I haven't kept up with >> You
know exactly what was shared. Don't fake or dudes. >> No,
I'm I work I like to work with I don't like to say full name
>> saying it's on your stream. >> You obviously you
you obviously know you you covered this content. You know that
he's leaked full name. I would I would rather we I would rather
we use an example that I'm like more famili like super familiar
with. Um I don't know like anyone who is like >> okay let's
take let's take face and full >> Yeah. What about it?
>> He's capping here because that's they're literally the
exact same thing and he called it a dox at the time. Oh boy.
>> Is that doxing?
is this is this is one of those dude this is like actually
very very rapidly and I don't use this reference lightly approaching
tom foolery tears of like setting yourself on fire like it's
actually getting I've not seen it since I first started streaming
I've not seen anything like that this is actually approaching
the tom foolery tier of just igniting yourself it's some Aaron
Bushnell crazy ass that we're witnessing right now dude it's
it's actually it's like dude Dude, all you have to do any any
step along the way, you could go, "Yeah, I'm a little cringe,
IRL. Sorry, guys. My bad. I I I'll be better and everything's
fine." You go, "Hey, yeah, I I was drunk and I shouldn't have
published that." It's actually really unforgivable. Like, I I
should apologize to Lio that I published that. Um, I put it in
a in a chat, a group chat, like a private chat, but it's not
that private. Uh, it's kind of [__] up with me. Just
anywhere along the way, you just go and hold an L and just be
like, "I up, guys." People will give you a little bit of leeway.
Are they right? Like you could say, "Oh, you know, I I was drunk
and I saw this thing and I I thought it was like public and I
Dude, I'm sorry, man." But like, okay, that's probably pretty
far. I still think he'd get away with it. It's like the showing
up and being defiant and telling people they're wrong for thinking
you're like doing something wrong that that people can't forgive
it, man. People can't let it go. People get so mad about it.
>> That's wrong. Even if if you want to add like a new
term under >> Do you guys remember when um do you guys
remember when I had that conversation with Sunday and Destiny
and I muted Sunday and then I I think I kicked him from the call
eventually or something and people were really mad at me. Could
you imagine if I'd come out the next time I streamed and said,
"You guys are for thinking that I shouldn't have muted Sunday.
You guys are all stupid for saying you know what I did? I I
put on my big boy pants and I said that was a mistake. I shouldn't
have done that.
A high pressure situation where like the vibes were kind of I
was I've already been kind of annoyed with Sunday in the past.
He burst on there and I I just reacted poorly. That was my bad.
Looked really bad. I up. Shouldn't have done it. And I remember
I think Smeaggel came on to press me and I'd already said like
he was like, "Oh, well I was coming on to I was coming on to
like to like say you [__] up." And it's like, "Yeah,
I know." He's like, "Oh, wow. You kind of took the wind out of
my sales here." I'm like, "Yeah, I know."
But that's what you got to do. When you actually make a mistake,
you do have to own it. If you are defiant about it, you will
get drilled into the [__] ground. You will get obliterated.
Okay? You You actually have to just sit there and and you've
got to take your medicine, let people get mad at you, and just
shut the [__] up. Okay?
You got to do it, man. You got to do it. It's the only way you
get through like that. Um and Aiden is doing the opposite here.
He's doing the Tom Foolery thing. Like, like I think the Sunday
thing is a judgment call. I felt like I didn't do anything wrong
at the time. And I'm like, I should still I like I just knew
it was a better idea. I I can identify now that it was like a
mistake. Like obviously mistake, but I was like emotional. people
were like getting really about it and yeah to just double down
and like not talk to friends and [__] I don't know
man. It'll it'll blow you up. It'll blow you up real bad. This
is rough to listen to. This is so much worse by the way. This
is so much worse. >> Which that's like a catch. >> You'll
think his favorite movie is Saving Private Ryan. >> That's
wrong. >> Wait, what is your example?
Are you I said we're not Can we use a different example than
I'm not super familiar with that. >> No, I'm giving you
the information. He leaked her full name and her face was >> You
know what? Yeah, that would be
If he was the first one to do it. Yes.
unfortunately there you can use one of the arguments for Willie
Mac. So, eight's going to go this seven sub YouTube channel that
had 10 views on the account when it posted like that information.
That's actually that's
a dude.
Dickers, I guarantee you Dickers like feels bad.
Dickers is like, "Please don't make me
brutally you on this stream. Please don't make me do this. Please."
Like, I feel like a lot of people would think this. Like, don't.
Come on, man. I don't want to do this. But then he comes in,
he says the dumbest. It's like Willy
wife.
You have to say it, man. You have to say it. H
rough. He What if he wasn't the first one to do it? >> What
if other people intentionally tried to spread it? Is that totally
fine?
>> now spreading the doc's information that you have agreed
is a doc if he's the one who originated it. Spreading that information
is totally aok. Okay. That's totally fine. >> Yes. How
are you want to say some?
>> Um, well, sorry. I was under the impression Aiden was
upset at me. He's just like coping about how he didn't do
>> Nobody's talking about who is when who is literally
who is talking about you? >> Keep crying [__]
I was >> Nobody is talking about you in here. Are you okay?
>> Stuff. And if that's the case, then you think if that's
the it also was republished in the case of bad empanada. I'm
not sure why you were saying that. Um, but just in general, >> yeah,
he doesn't if he doesn't know the specifics is whatever. But
sorry, >> that's why I don't care to work with your like
we could we could just we could talk about like general concepts.
We don't need to always relate it back to something. >> I
think if you're not [__] you're probably going to
work like within a level of caution about what these topics are.
But maybe that's just me. >> If we're arguing
>> God, I think I had
the stream started off so good today. I don't know why we just
had like big viewership, big chatters. I wish I'd been following
this stuff. I wish I would have asked uh asked Dickers to hop
on
because I feel like I could have cleared this up super fast for
them,
but I just wasn't I wasn't on top of this one today. >> For
for a conceptual understanding of what doxing is, like somebody
who's like a competent uh debater would be able to just formulate
like a general
said that your definition is false. >> Okay,
now Aiden is saying something that's totally correct. Dickers
normally comes off as a competent debater. I don't know why he's
not just giving it includ
time on this conversation that we didn't have. You >> like
you have this obsession. >> I've already given you the
revision. I don't know why I don't know why you're trying to
like pretend again again that nobody else has got an idea of
what they mean when they say the word doxing. I've said your
definition is fine. Add on and they're family members. Yeah,
I I and I'm arguing that family members >> and you've already
admitted that the original dissemination would be a dox, but
then you said that spreading the dox is fine. So, we've already
got to a definition of doxing that we agree on because you've
been reading the Willy M show argument or the Willy M show
you went silent for 30 seconds
and then you admitted that yes, it was substance. What I'm explaining
to you is that that family member qualifier as I've just laid
out the argument for uh my premise has not been contested.
The family member qualifier is actually it falls under the branch
of PII. So the definition doesn't need to be revised because
the family membership
>> how does personally identifiable information spread
across several people. It doesn't >> like it fundamentally
underly the entire purpose is to harass people and you're posting
the information of the person who could be harassed. a person
who could be harassed ostensibly
apparently and he didn't deny this to pressure Leo Convoy knowing
that his the premise the the idea of his wife being harassed
would pressure him right like like it's it seems
like this is performative
okay we do have Schroinger's over here >> wait what are
you taught what >> could Dickers to be fair like if you
know that somebody
could that that's not even true that's not even true >> sure
that did docks because he was revealing PII about Leo there you
Yeah, but it's not true to say that Li that Aiden doxed Lio >> or
that he's sharing doc's information about Lio, right? He's sharing
doc.
>> That's the argument I would be making. >> Obviously,
well, you and I are clearly very different people on this topic.
So, yeah, I'm not making the same arguments as you. >> Well,
it's hard to say that.
>> It's just it's sad that like Aiden's position so clearly
so clearly
only being generated. It's like it's just entirely downstream
of the current controversy he's in. Like it wouldn't hold up
at any other time. I doubt you could find any other similar situation
he's been in where he would like hold this as his definition.
Um it is Yeah, it doesn't. >> You can imagine if um Aiden
doxes Leo's wife and that includes her address, but I don't know
if it did. Well, that would obviously also be doxing Leo. So,
he can be doing both. He can be doing both, >> Liar is
already public about his address, so no. >> He didn't leak
anybody's address. >> Sure. No, he's just like around posting
Leo Convoy's wife and he is also Doxing Kerr, but he would say
that because she's not a figure that's okay, I guess. >> Not
only her legal name, but the the name that she goes by at work
as well, >> which uh she's like completely unnecessary
work. Wait, why do he I know nothing about her work. I don't
know where she works. I don't know what I don't know what her
work >> Shut the [__] up, bro. You know, you've
told me you've told me that you know what she does for work.
I just >> You told me that you know that it's publicly
available. >> What is her work? Is she like a drag queen?
What do you mean her work name?
>> Do you have a separate name? >> Obviously, I'm
not going to go Obviously, I'm not going to go into that. I'm
going to have this entire argument with a hand behind my back.
>> You know that she goes by a different name at work for
reasons that you know. >> I swear on my life. This is the
first time I've ever I swear on my life that
Oh, he's he's Oh, this is brutal. I feel like Dickers is going
to have to I wonder if Dickers has any way to prove this or if
it's just like I guess both him and Queen could give their word
on this, right? >> Because I do know I I do know I do know
stuff about her. That is actually the first time I've heard that.
Thank you for telling the audience.
I've literally never That's not true at all. You've actually
you've actually gotten you've gotten info about >> I got
that information from Actually
>> Actually, Dickers. Actually, Dickers, when you think
about it, you're the one who doxed her, Dickers. I thought you
didn't want to do that in your own stream, Dickers. Why are you
doxing Leo Comvoy's wife on your stream, Dickers?
Oh my god, dickers. You just doxed Leo Comboy's wife on your
stream, dickers. >> How have I learned this information?
all this information I have got from you. >> How could
I How could I talk about something that I don't know about? I
don't know what she I >> I'm saying that you're lying and
that you do know and you're being intentionally obsent because
you know that I can't like reveal this while I'm on live stream.
>> That I brought up her place of work. What was the place
of work? Damn it to me. Damn it to me. >> What? I'm not
going to [__] and you've already said on this stream
that apparently that was a fake doc that you came up with. >> No,
no. I'm asking you to repeat that. You've said you have said
that is obviously a face dox, but given what this woman does
for work and given that you've already given her full name, finding
out her workplace is trivial. >> No, I'm saying I'm saying
you're alleging that I like know all this stuff about her work
in her work name. So, I'm asking you, >> you know what
she does for work. >> Okay, you are claiming that I said
something. I'm asking you and I understand why you care. Dude,
the amount of information that you have given me about what this
woman does for her work and the things that you know that she's
done in the course of her work is insane given the fact that
now you're trying to trying to claim that you don't know any
of this information. Yes or no? You told me
I'm told I don't know why you're trying to [__] I
don't know why you're trying to like ramble and rant now. You're
trying I'm giving you the argument right now to try and jog your
memory since you are lying. You have given me information that
you know that of what about this what this woman's done in the
course of her work. You know what she does for work. You're trying
to put me in a position in the situ in the argument now where
I have to say her name. Yes, you do. >> No, I don't. Dude,
you're literally I have to prove I have to prove that I don't
know something. That's how delusion. Like that's how neurotic
you are. My question to you would be to substantiate that I apparently
know this info about her and you you're only getting this info
just from me apparently is and I'm not asking you to say this
to your stream. I'm not asking you to dox her. DM me privately
where you were alleging I said that she worked. That shouldn't
be a problem. >> No, that's not what we're talking about.
Cuz you've already said in the court, you're trying to distract.
It's like not even [__] working to anyone who's listening
to conversation. Let me [__] finish, bro. I'm responding
to what you're saying. Okay. So, you've already said you've already
said >> that the information that you gave me about where
she worked was a fake doc. That one particular point in the information
isn't true. So, I don't know why you're trying to ask me for
that information when you're already claiming that it's a fake
doc. >> Yeah, I am. I I I am. What is that? How's that
contradictory?
>> Because you're trying to ask me for information that
is totally irrelevant to this argument right now. >> Cuz
what I'm doing
you're jumping from the fact that she's got two names into the
fact that she has like a certain work. You're going to DM me
the institution that she's never worked at. That's going to prove
>> Yeah. I'm saying about the thing that you've claimed
that it's a fake it's a full stock. I've already several times
work there because it's a fake die. >> If you actually
I mean I'll do the meta commentary that you like to do with debates.
Okay. If you were confident on the argument right now, you wouldn't
be sitting on this one point that I've already conceded. You're
claiming that it's a fake doc. >> Wait, you're What have
you conceded on?
>> That you are claiming in this conversation it's a fake
doc.
>> No, I'm just to be clear, I'm not just claiming if Dickers
actually went and looked up wherever he thinks I said she >> I
don't know about you, dude. I've got no interest in looking up
liar convoys white docs. That's me personally.
understand if you don't really understand that. >> I'm
claiming that you said that you were giving out LIO combo workplace
work name. You've lied. Shut the [__] up, dude. It's
not lied. You've already said this [__] lied,
>> dude. Shut the up. Did you or did you not spread Lio's
wife's full name? Do you want to know why and what she does for
work? Yes or no? Yes or no? Yes or no? Can I just finish my line
of dialogue and then I'll have >> No, I'm asking you a
question right now. You're not doing a line of dialogue. You're
trying to [__] soap box and give a speech. >> Okay,
just to be clear, that is like super photoshopped. Okay, did
you or did you not give wife
in a manner that would make falsifiable >> and face?
>> Sorry, I was just talking. You can >> you said
Okay, let's see if this jogs your jogs your memory. You shared
a name.
I said >> uh I think I think Dickers might hop on right
away. I'm
>> It's not actually Dickers. I just said that to be annoying.
Hold on. >> Is that her surname? >> Somebody calling
in. We'll see. >> And you said Oh, not anymore. >> But
what is Do you mean her maiden name? >> Yes. I was under
the belief that you'd originally sh
>> I can't believe that you started this by calling me
dickers. Seriously, it's been I haven't spoken to you this year.
This is how this is how we're starting it. Is it just talk? >> That's
true. You have not spoken to me this year. That is true. I'm
sorry. I Listen, I've uh I got like 2 hours of sleep and then
I was going to stream for like 3 hours and I ended up I'm on
like hour 10 now cuz I can't stop now that I started. It's too
good.
I'm reaching for every piece of fruit.
>> So, Bro, this is this is unbelievable.
I just look I someone did message me and was like look I know
you're like because I'm I'm on a short hiatus at the moment and
like are you seeing this? Are you are you like what's your opinion?
I was like it's indefensible. What's going on?
>> Wild. And do you think like after he did it, do you
think he could have gotten away? Cuz I I said this and maybe
I'm not sure about it. I I I posited it and I'm not totally sure
because I think a lot of times if you just apologize like right
away you can get along along you can get away with a lot of really
bad behavior possibly right like if he' just been like oh I was
drunk he was hammered and this was like I'm super sorry obviously
this is totally unacceptable
I'm basically acting like Leo convoy I don't know why I do this
and just apologized yeah cuz Leo wouldn't have made a big deal
out of it
um >> so cuz
gone on like screaming and crying about it for days. They just
been like, "Yeah, sure." So, yeah. Yeah. Um, this blew up entirely.
Much like Yeah. I mean, much like Tom Foolery, it's it's completely
self-inflicted. I I don't know what the [__] he's
doing. I don't get it. >> Yeah. In in a way that like baffles
like literally I'm sure all of his friends I'm sure everybody's
just like, "Dude, you got to you got to not do this." And he's
like, "No, I can do that. One more defense, one more debate.
I'll I'll get it this time. I can totally flip it. It's
crazy. I just Yeah, I saw the jewelry comparison. It's wild.
>> If I think if you spread Doc's information about a content
creator who you're beefing with and it's in some way relevant.
I think let's say Lio's name wasn't public like uh good old Thomas
didn't give a like was super protected but like Lio doesn't care
about that sort of stuff. Um >> yeah. And Aiden stumbled
across that information. Lio had doxed people and Aiden was like,
"I'm gonna say your real name because you're a doxer." No one
would care. But like, this isn't just going at a content creator.
You're attacking somebody's like you're you're bringing someone's
family into it. Like I think there's an additional like stage
here where it's like you're so mad at this person that you're
prepared to weaponize their family against them. >> And
it's like you just don't like there's no excuse for it. There's
no justification at all.
Well, and you I don't know if you watched this whole call. Did
you watch this call between Perry? >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I watched it all through Quan. Uh, so I've seen a little bit
now. So >> So like it seems like and I I didn't see what
Queenman said when he watched this, but it seems like Aiden didn't
really push back when Dicker said, "No, no, no. You told me and
Queen privately. You confided in us explicitly that this was
to pressure Lio into having a com combo with you." It's like,
okay. So, like it's it's like explicitly malicious.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is. It's absolutely malicious. I mean,
there's What other reason? I I've seen now the YouTube video
this came from. By the way, I didn't even know Liia's wife's
name. So, like this idea that cuz like Aiden's been pushing,
well, people knew this. This is public. I've never heard Liar's
wife's name before. >> Yeah. Cuz there's a seven YouTube
channel with a 10 view video that's got it in it. >> Yeah.
I mean, I I think we're pushing the brackets of what we're considering
public here, really.
>> well, that's I mean, that's probably even less forgivable
than a like Facebook page, right? Like you found their Facebook
page. I feel like that's even more buried. >> Maybe you
can say because it pops up in search, it's less buried. >> I
mean, here's but here's here's the problem. when you start like
pushing to like these levels every like there's no such thing
as doxing anymore because like what you're essentially doing
is like a doc is maliciously gathering information in people
and then disseminating it. >> That's that's what doxing
is. Isn't it convenient that Aiden forgot Aiden the the debate
bro who's never up a definition in his life forgot the most common
definition of doxing to have this conversation like the one it
literally falls under the one that literally would have just
solved this whole definition argument they have for like 45 minutes
>> like you >> you published somebody's PII you collected
it you published it for the purpose of harassment
>> yeah I mean I I made this point on Hamilton's stream
there are people I
And I know that their information's been spread. In fact, actually,
taking it aside from people I don't like, just let's just take
the example of President Sunday. Sunday was doxed what years
ago,
>> everyone was basically polite enough not to spread that
around and we all understood just because like one person has
said his name
like we said like it's not like it's not spread into the public
consciousness because the first time Sunday was doxed it was
through a Twitter account which was posting as like his full
name uh with a picture of him and no one picked up on that. no
one ran with it because we all understood that that would still
be spreading docs information cuz it's a tiny Twitter account
with like no followers that everyone just blocked. Or if somebody
like what's the line line here? If somebody comes into a into
a chat in kick and somebody like posts somebody's address, you
know, like the thing where you like spam people's docs in a chat.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> If that happens once, am
I then completely free to regurgitate that information?
I was like, "Oh, no, no. chatter has randomly said in my chat
your full name and address. So, I'm actually fine to say that
on stream. Nobody would accept that as an argument. It's crazy.
>> Oh man. And that just makes me think of like Aiden came
in and said the full name on the stream right off the bat and
mentioned like a workplace. It's like dude, are you like h sorry,
this is like an aside point that you just made me remember, but
I I thought that was particularly gross when when literally the
argument is Dickers believes you dox this person. you come, you
go, "No, there isn't even a doc here. Look, I could talk about
her name and her like her place of employment." It's like, "Bro,
what?" And then he tried to go, "Well, I didn't even verify it.
I don't even like know I don't even know if that's true." It's
like, dude,
the [__]
this is this is I mean, this is bad. This is like a a hard line
kind of thing. Like, what the [__] you doing? Like,
I I can get past the vague posting. Like he was vague posting
that he knew Li's wife's information on Twitter and I don't really
I don't really care about vague posting. I think that goes like
back to like the skeptic days with like Jeff Holiday. I don't
care about the vague posting [__] Like >> he
vague posted before, but I'd say like the vague posting sets
you up for like now I know your intent in having this information.
If you're menacing somebody this information and then you publish
it, you don't have the oh well >> the secondary the the
publishing thing needs to happen in my opinion. Like I'm not
moral
if you're just saying I'll do >> Yeah. Exactly. Like it's
when you do it, >> but you don't cancel somebody over it,
right? Like it's it's >> it's like you shouldn't do it.
It's obviously faux, but people hate each other. They say crazy
all the time. >> Saying making like a threat isn't necessarily
indicative of that you'll actually follow through.
>> But it's just like, dude, you're
just take the L. Just be like, I'm sorry that was The big thing
is Aiden's obviously been going at liar for ages. Um, which is
I've defended Aiden doing this, by the way. Like I I have been
really defensive of Aiden and like Aiden's not doing it. >> No,
I'm not. Now I I mean he's lost all moral high ground. The problem
the problem is this. Like the the problem is this. A's argument
is that the stuff Low Convoy has done is inexcusably bad over
the years and therefore he should be condemned. Lo's response
is I've apologized for many of the things I think are still bad,
but many of the things I did I think I was completely justified
in doing because they were groomers or they were or they were
this or they were that.
And the problem is that Aiden's just gone, "Okay, well, I'll
accept that because this person is bad, I can use these tactics."
You're literally just agreeing with now strategy. Like, >> congratulations.
Well done. You've like
>> What moral high ground do you have? That was Aiden's
entire argument for this Liio. Lio is morally evil. Okay. You've
targeted somebody's wife. How like your
Did you think like what what what happened to any kind of moral
codes? It's ridiculous.
>> That is nothing, man. Yeah. O, dude. Uh what about the
what about the gokado stuff? Cuz I haven't really gotten to that
yet. I um >> Holy [__] The goat cat stuff in
this call is bad. It's bad. >> Yeah, I haven't got Hold
on. I haven't gotten to any of the stuff in this call yet. I
just got to the parry leaking thing and I'm like, "Oh,
did you did you you watch the whole thing through Creamman? Did
you hear the whole thing? Did you see like most of the Perry
VOD?"
>> Uh, I haven't seen most of the Perry
>> I haven't seen much happens in the Perry >> Okay.
What happens in the Perry Vod? >> Um, it is that. So, maybe
they confirm a whole bunch of stuff in this call and it doesn't
matter. But like basically what happens is Perry starts leaking
this stuff and goat Katos in the chat and she like does like
dot dot dot and she doesn't respond at all. She goes away for
like 45 minutes or an hour. Okay. Soul Skippy the other guy who's
at the bar with them joins the chat starts reaming Perry you're
such a
you you're such a and I start laughing when he does this. I'm
like soul god bless his heart probably trying to be a good friend
here. in fact doesn't realize that he is the counterpoints to
go cats Lauren Southern and he has just fully like confirmed
that this is a conversation they had. this is something they
discuss seriously and he wouldn't react like this like I think
he might say at one point you're like twisting it with little
lies but it's like that means the core piece there is probably
true right >> well it does seem that there's some sort
of like so Aiden admits that he likes go actually there's something
interesting here that I actually want to ask you I seem to remember
Aiden giving you over the cherry stuff >> um yeah probably
>> I I'm unaware of that >> but probably >> so
yeah like um So, he got to know Goat because Goat was like attacked
by Lio.
I'm massively like broad brushing things and is now getting involved
with this person that he's like fronted as like a victim of somebody
who he's going after for that reason.
>> So, again, it's like like
how the [__] are you doing? You again, you would
critic people for the way you were acting like what are you what?
>> Yeah. No, it's if he if he made those criticisms.
Yeah, I dude I
that sucks. I
listen I just take whatever people had criticisms for that. I
mostly just take it. Um cuz I I find what I find people do is
they um like in a situation like that where you had a critic
who criticized you for something where there's like some valid
criticism there. I find a lot of people will try to relitigate.
And I know that the first step to relitigating is like trying
to dance on this guy's grave if I see a hypocrisy or something.
So I >> Yeah. No, that's why that's why I've come to do
it for you. >> Yeah. Yeah. No, I think I think the hypocrisy
is like wild. I I listen I I know that people do the whole thing
of like I hate hypocrisy hunting. But I think I think as a commentator
you do need to try and be consistent. Everyone's everyone's got
little inconsistencies,
but it's rare to get a story like this where it's just like every
level's insane. Aiden comes from commentary. He knows the standards
around doxing and information uh release and he knows the standards
with like other people and again it's not even directly Lio.
He's doxing Lio's wife.
Um I think he says in this conversation he's like well it doesn't
matter because she's not a public figure. So you can't dock somebody
who's not a public figure. And that's absolutely just not the
case. That's not the reality. I don't I don't know why the he
said
>> did he say public figure at some point? Cuz yeah, you
definitely could dock somebody who's not public. He I He was
trying to do the like connecting a public public information
or sorry, what would you say? Like uh
oh, personally identifiable information. >> Yeah, she's
not like she's not like
a m she's not like a content critter or whatever. And it's like
>> but it seemed like he was harping on you have to connect
it to like a pseudo anonymous ID online. Well, not even like
public. But I was like, dude, you would dox Elon Musk by posting
his address, right? Like obviously,
>> Yeah. But maybe he was
personally made available because like so for instance you can't
face dox me. I've made my face available. You can't dox locomboy's
name. He's made his name available many many times but his wife
hasn't done that. And like specifically what we're talking about
here is like because it's like you could obviously trace back
through like Lio's address and everything and work out who this
person is. But that is you doxing somebody. That is you compiling
information on somebody to use maliciously because the point
here is to apply pressure to LIO so that liio is forced into
a conversation. I mean it's >> the definition of what of
at least spreading doxed information.
>> Yeah. And
oh man,
he was basically he also tried to argue for a second that like
this was actually more like doxing Lio because his wife didn't
have a public persona. And it's like wait but who's going to
get what's the point of this information like doxing to harass
somebody? Who's going to get harassed with her face, name, occupation,
place of work? Who who are we expecting to get harass? Is Lio
going to get harassed? I mean technically by I guess you know
like collaterally he might get har but it's your post >> I
think I think I sent you a message cuz he posted it in he posted
it in Icy I think I I got sent this I sent you a >> a thing
of hisification. Can we can we bring that up very quickly? I
just want to address it. >> Yeah. Yeah. I got it. I got
it up here already. So I'll read it here. Uh Lia literally called
the disabled kids parents to convince them to keep beating him.
That's uh tragically funny as much as it sounds horrific. Okay.
This fat cow stays with Lio, houses him, feeds him, clothes him
as an accomplice to actually care for to actually care. Her face
got posted in a private Discord chat. Uh, this is a total cope,
too. The private Discord chat meme about Icy. Get the [__]
out of here. >> It's a public discord. We all know it's
public. Shut the [__] up. Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah.
It's like it take What do you need to be in his Discord for like
a week to get into Icy chat? Like, come on, bro. What are you
talking about? And make a scene publicly just works to serve
this fat self victimhood narrative. self victim of narrative.
So Dickers essentially helped oh god helped a guy who encouraged
a minor to create over a photo of his wife that was made public
like three years ago. See, here's here's also like one of the
core problems here and that's why I want to sort of like address
it because
>> Lio had Lio has never encouraged a minor to create
>> and like one of the criticisms that Aiden gets
is he says things just aren't true and he's hyperbolic with the
statements but you can't like that's a serious accusation to
make
like >> accusing somebody of like
I don't know it's just
Bro needs to br needs to chill the [__] out. I don't
I don't know what the
I don't know what the answer is here as well because part of
the problem is if Aiden gets annoyed enough at somebody, here's
the standard now. If Aiden gets annoyed enough at somebody, he'll
release private information on them. So, how can you trust or
work with Aiden?
>> unless you're like fully doxed already, basically, like
if you don't have private information. I mean, I'd say just No,
I don't even think that applies because realistically, as much
as you know, Willie Mack would have you believe that in the in
the online politics space you just dox whoever, it's like you
should never accept that standard. Like, you can just go back
to, oh, actually, this is still wrong. Even though some people
got doxed, it's actually still wrong. So, I think probably you
just don't want the reputation of working with somebody who's
willing to do it do this, right?
>> I would say that you just like I I'm more of a forgiving
person that if this guy does turn and go, "Actually, I really
up. I didn't think about this." And like I would say he could
still apologize for it. He's >> like, "Yeah, but man, I
I don't know why >> I think it can be apologized for
>> I don't I feel like there's another thing going on here
that is
>> Yeah, I don't know why you just wouldn't apologize.
I just That just seems really obvious. She's like, "Yeah, this
is a mess." Um, save some face. I mean, he's kind of it's Yeah,
it's the
it's the basic thing of, well, you can't
criticize Lio for going after people's families. You've just
done that. And it's not it was also just not acceptable to be
like, well, I did it to Lio
uh because Lio did it. It's like, well, if that's your standard,
what's going to stop somebody coming and going, well, I'd go
after Aiden's family because he did that to Lio. like
>> it just becomes a self it like just becomes self-feeding.
>> I I also think like
man you don't know the dynamic. I get where he's I s I get the
argument he's making but man I think we've pretty much decided
as a society that this is we've drawn a line before this like
not just commentary like humanity has basically said the way
like human rights works is you don't get held responsible for
like the actions of your spouse or something like you don't get
executed necessarily if you're not complicit and it's like maybe
if she if you had some evidence that she was like helping him
do doc like helping him dox or super supportive of it but it's
like uh I happen to be personally aware of situations where the
partner of someone who was engaging in like a doxing campaign
wanted nothing to do with that, was not supportive of it, was
very unhappy with it, right? And it's like to go after that person
without knowing their opinion, without knowing like how they're
dealing with it privately, it just seems like totally unfair,
not a not a principle most people would support, right? >> The
Trump
terrorist families. Yeah. bomb terrorist families here. Like,
no, no, we probably shouldn't bomb terrorist families. It's pretty
[__] up.
>> I mean, from from seeing um
kind of how this unfolded with Tom Foolery, what's your opinion?
Do you think it's going the same way? Do you think this is just
the double down? We'll see like Aiden bring up Goat Casu's nudes
on stream >> in like a week. >> So, I think he Dude,
Jesus. >> Oh, dude, that was such a kino drama.
>> She's kind of like she's kind of tomboyish. She could
he could get away with the you know that's actually trans man
just so you know that's actually trans man. >> Yeah. No
man like dude dude history history never repeats but certainly
rhymes. Um it's just
bro I like I think one of the funniest things as well is uh Goat
was in chat um like during this conversation like sitting no
Aiden did say these things. He did this did happen. is like completely
him over.
Um are you are you Yeah, it gets it it does get worse. Like oh
has asked one particular question
>> where it just
>> like I mean goth girls man not even once, right? Like
>> I saw I think I think Queenman sent me a screenshot.
I just went like dude this woman is evil whole why why just why?
I actually don't know, dude. It's like she saw the weakness there.
It was just like this guy. I swear there's like some biological
thing there. She just saw that he was weak and was like, "You
know what? I'm switching sides." I don't know, man. There's something
totally about it. I don't know how to explain it. Okay. You know
that she's got a DM from morale right now asking to play Project
Zomboid. You know that, right? >> Dude, I mean, [__]
hell. What an what start to the year. Like, I knew the meetups
were going to go badly.
Um, I had like this feeling like cuz I was going to go down the
eighth and
>> I like I dodged a bullet. I don't I don't know. Getting
getting sick apparently um saved me. I just
Good. Good for me. I guess
>> all I know is okay there's there's some cosmic force
that if you're mean enough to hellbent, okay, don't be mean to
Hellbent. Be like nice, okay? Some something will destroy you
if you are mean enough to hellbent. Okay. It's been proven. You
got to be very careful.
Oh
>> Yeah. I mean I I saw Quean originally talk about the
meetup
>> and weirdly enough like the the story Queen told about
like uh the dinner and things and Aiden having no table manners
uh was brutal. It was genuinely really brutal. I don't know if
I'd go that I'd have gone that far. It was just it painted Aiden
in such a particularly
uh pathetic light.
I'm wondering whether that's crash. >> Yeah. Like Okay,
cool. I'll leave you to watch the rest of it. It's good to good
to chat with you. I hope you have a hope I hope you have a great
2026, man. Um uh >> it's getting better with this stuff.
But yeah, it was good chatting. Thanks for coming on. >> Yeah.
Yeah. No worries, man. Catch you in a bit. Peace. Yeah. All right.
See you. Bye.
we're going to keep watching. Okay. We got to get to the gokado
stuff. There's only tops an hour left in the VOD. All right.
We're going to try to get through it. We got to go. We got to
go. >> So, what is a work name?
Is that what you meant?
>> You guys called Okay.
>> Okay. So, to catch you guys back up, um, Dickers is
basically accusing Aiden of Dickers to win this argument is going
to have to publish private information. He's going to have to
like basically make these arguments directly to Aiden publicly
on the stream. He's saying, "I don't trust you to even DM you
about it." Like,
Aiden's shown no discretion here in terms of what he'll like
talk about on the stream. So, Dickers is arguing that Aiden's
basically looking for like I don't know, he's essentially almost
trying to make Dicker's docs.
No, no, don't. That literally was the point of confusion. >> She
got that's her full her name like the full name. She I think
she's already made a name like in her name or some [__]
cuz that's the name of the channel. >> What you done? You
were defending doxing lawyers wife's name face occupation. Apparently
the workplace turned out to be not true. Um okay fine. So I'm
saying that on the night and you agree that you changed your
take. >> Why? Cuz then you said
in a very very >> I'm questioning that. I'm asking you
what was you accepted that earlier. >> Okay. So no. So
just for clarification we started. Okay. I'm going to ask people
to go back in the stream and when Eden is first calling in, I
reference that you are taking the L on a topic and you say, "I
do still take the L. I do still take the L." I don't defend.
>> This is totally different. >> I don't defend it.
That's what you were saying earlier 30 minutes ago.
>> You are lying.
>> I I'll be real with you guys. I kind of want to go to
bed, but I also I have to watch to the end. I have to make it
to the end now. We're committed. Um >> about not remembering
changing your position. Where was the What was the change? I'm
just asking what the change was. told you the change is Aiden
and you've already accepted there was a change earlier cuz you
originally have Don't cut me off the >> You said originally
that you were not defending it that you were not going back that
you still took the L and now you've changed it partway through
this conversation you know you are lying >> that would
be the conclusion there's no lie cuz there's no claim I'm asking
>> you're so dishonest dude I can't [__] believe
this >> wait what is the lie
>> you're lying now about not remembering ever changing
your position >> I just didn't attempt things okay so as
I've stated before argument ments that are relying like previous
reruns of such argument especially when some participants were
admittedly drunk. There's going to be greater room for
>> I'm saying that we can agree on what has happened
for this. >> Okay, so let dude stop with the [__]
monologues, man. Holy. You're roboting while you're doing it.
It's not [__] working. Do we agree yes or no? You
change your position >> on what? Can you explain what the
change was and I'll agree or disagree
>> on the topic of whether it was moral or not to share
Liar's wife's information what this entire conversation is about.
>> So your claim was that I was arguing morality of it.
>> You went to Pete.
Lie Simon ill thank you very much for the new sub. Appreciate
it dude. Appreciate it a lot. Wait was that what actually popped
though?
Brand new sub. Is that what it was? Oh no, it was Private Huff
with the gifted sub. We had we had Ill Simon Lie Simon ill and
and Private Huff. Thank you guys so much for the subs. Appreciate
it.
>> So my first clan was >> you were sharing you you
had a definitional argument and you had a moral argument, but
yeah, it was all towards a moral conclusion. >> Wait, wait.
Okay. So So I did I change the definitional argument?
>> You didn't change anything, bro. You asked Spinling
and Go to contact me so that then you could jump in and say,
"I take the L. I up." You never gave your reasoning. I was just
happy accepting it because you took the L and you took it >> A
reasonable question to ask. >> What? What's a reasonable
question to
>> Can you hear me? >> Yeah, I can hear you. You're
asking what was a reasonable question to ask? >> How
do these resolve anytime soon?
We have to keep skipping along.
>> Okay, my stream health is like totally
So what I'm Yeah, the conversation did happen. He want >> Oh,
the conversations did happen. He wanted to to get Dickers in
VC in my priv. So me and someone else DM Dickers so they could
talk. Oh,
hold on. We need the chat to pop up here. Chat disabled for this
live stream in my private. >> Gay dickers. Gay.
No chat. Gay.
it. So, me and somebody else DM'd us so they could talk. I don't
remember what uh what all was said, but obviously doxing's wife
isn't a good idea. Okay. So, I guess
did we just get from that >> You were asking earlier if
I could prove the statements that you made. So, presumably,
it was obviously not good to dox's wife. Okay. So, apparently
Aiden must have been of the opinion that he docks Lio's wife
before,
right? And then he came on today and was like, there is no docs.
Here's much of this.
I accepted. So, so this is going to be verifiable and I'm going
to clip it. So, >> uh I had to go back and cut out the
Oh, you did that. Well, we definitely have transmitted that today.
Unfortunately, >> I actually said earlier and if claims
otherwise is going to be lying, right? I I we accepted earlier
that there was a VC with goat and spinling that wasn't like really
contested.
Um so, what I'm saying was Oh, this is what I was [__]
saying. Here we go. So, what I was saying earlier,
>> oh boy. >> Yeah. was that you never gave your
reasoning for why you were taking the L. You agree >> at
the time?
>> I mean I don't worry about it. Like we'll we'll probably
mute that stuff or whatever. I Riyle will figure it out. I trust
Riyle. Okay. Riyle add Leo Doc SL. Do not actually hold on. I
don't even want to make the joke. I was going to say get her
info yourself and then um and then censor it like through your
like put it in the script is as a bad word and then I realized
don't actually say that but if you do hear the name okay I need
to be very careful that was very close to >> then that
just sounds like there was an >> just where whatever that
name is if it were related to Star Wars perhaps we should cut
that name out of the
you just took good >> yeah so let's so let's give an argument
so I'm asking Why did you take the L to begin with? I'm trying
to get that >> but I don't I like honestly I don't like
I don't remember the details like what what was happening at
3:00 a.m. the night I was drunk when we were like dealing with
this. Like >> you can remember the day afterwards, but
>> that's why like that's what I'm saying. Why don't we
just want to rerun the argument? Why don't we want to redate
this? Why does it need to be like >> Okay, earlier in this
conversation, this is what I was saying earlier. Earlier in this
conversation, you said that you were still taking the L and you
were not going to defend it. >> And I asked you several
times to clarify what you were and were not defending. And then
you changed it mid-con conversation. People go back. >> Um,
by the way, Dickers, if you wanted an example of like people
you could dox who don't have public profiles, I would say the
um like individual employees of gaming companies that Asmin Gold
was doxing to get fired over the Charlie Kirk nonsense, right?
Or whatever random [__] he was doxing people over.
Like that would be an example of people without generally public
profiles that you are absolutely collecting information on and
publishing or directly harassing yourself as in like messaging
their employers and so like you don't need to have a public profile.
It doesn't have to be attached to some pseudonym
anonymous ID. Uh Aiden just forgot the primary definition of
doxing for some reason in this argument. I have no idea why.
Collecting private information and then publishing that private
information for the purpose of harassment. Different ways to
say it, but that's broadly what it is. I have no idea how he
forgot it. Seems pretty motivated to me. What he said was mid
>> I'm taking in regards to the argument that I think you're
you refused to actually give like the full you're like doing
this like time travel debate share or you want to go back to
like >> I'm doing time travel debate
in here.
Why don't you just want to rerun the argument now? What is this
obsession? >> We did rerun the argument. >> What
is this obsession? And you've said that spreading spreading doc
information is totally fine for we've run the argument again.
You've said that spreading doc information is totally
>> Okay. So, it's going to depend on the >> You said
that for Will's wife, it was totally fine. Will you be given
that in terms of context? Cuz apparently you've got no clue what
happened with Millax's
>> You claimed that you you claimed you claimed you claimed
that it is totally fine to be able to spread that
>> Yeah. So, so I've explained the problems I have with
>> We already had we already had this hypothes. If you
if you wish you could go back and give a different answer. Okay.
So, here's fair enough. Do I need to teach you how to run an
argument? So, what we do is we agree. >> Don't be such
a condescending. >> Let's figure out what the disagreement
here is. What is the disagreement there, guys? What are we disagreeing
on? >> All I know for sure is this Aiden guy is winning.
Okay, just one more. Just one more time, Aiden. Just one more
argument. One more call in.
We get it all back. Get you can win it all. You can get it all
back.
>> You tell me. You called in. >> No, wait. You're
You're >> You called in. You called in. >> You're
You're refuting something I said, >> You called in to take
issue with something I had said. >> Oh, no. The thing Okay.
Okay. So, we already went over some of the issues. So, you already
conceded on the workplace [__] that you got that
wrong. Um, we already got you. You're claiming now that it's
a fake. That's what you're put on. I'm not even wrong. I'm happy
to take it for the I'm I'm happy to >> Wait,
did Queman not let him call in? Did he say he wanted to call
into Quimman's stream and Que was like, "No, man. I think it's
better if you don't. I think it's better if you take the night
>> Take it for granted given the fact that I don't have
additional information to be able to prove or disprove it. I'm
giving you
lied about it. It's like actually no. All the information would
suggest like you actually have nothing that would suggest like
that I revealed this person's workplace. Um you got nothing to
suggest you revealed this woman face or name. You can't even
tell me. You can't even out of my way to be able to confirm this.
When somebody's going to complain about somebody doxing
didn't want to be the black guy crying with the revolver. So
he's not ready to put he's not ready to take Nicholas Yorio's
place yet. Okay. Didn't want to put him out to pasture. Oh boy.
>> Out the way to be able to confirm whether or not it
is No fireside chats from natural dogs or >> Okay. Okay.
In this instance, if you're if you're So, if one party is claim,
of course, if if it's the claims of one party, if it's dude,
especially given the fact that all along you've shown me where
you found this, you believe that this is information. >> Of
course, you would go out of your way to confirm that. Are you
>> No, Aiden, you are clearly >> I would say probably
like
regardless.
Oh, man. It says something about Aiden that he posted this stuff
in the first place, right? Obviously.
Oh jeez, it's late. Uh, he said he had not realized Elum Aiden
was taking things
>> Oh, I should watch that. Don't [__] give
me this information.
That's about I don't need to give you a refresher. Why would
you >> You believe this information is doc's information.
Morally, that's all I care
>> You believe this to be doc.
>> That's all that I care about. and you've been continuous.
Let me [__] this is not going to [__]
work your monologue. >> Okay, I'm not going I'm not ranting
at all. You said that the name face and occupation that you gave
were legit and you've only claimed that the workplace was apparent
you lied about that. But >> who said I
lied about that? >> Let him have the floor. >> What
are you talking about? >> Who said I lied? You just said
apparently I lied about that. Who's saying I lied about that?
>> Oh, I thought you were saying that somebody Okay. No.
What I thought you were just doing was saying that somebody said
no no wait. So the this is like a sentence like if we could just
get through one I know your ADHD is like so what I was trying
to what I was >> dude dude that's that's a
that's an aerodite play right there.
You're like trying to dude this is so bad when you're far enough
behind in the in the argument right that you start like trying
to talk trying to throw the other person and they're like they
could see that you're drowning. You're like literally you're
literally holding an anchor. You're in the middle of the ocean.
There's Dickers is on a boat. Aiden is holding an anchor. He's
slowly going underwater and he's like Dickers. And Dickers is
like, "Yeah, I like I don't know what you think's going on in
this situation, but I'm literally watching you sink. Like you
can't make me think that you're a threat, right? Like you're
literally you I'm watching you sink right now."
>> I was telling you I was telling you that the information
about the workplace like we were accepting that that was fake,
right? That that was fake or I was accepting that was fake. I
don't know. You're like on the fence about that. You're like
uncertain or whatever. And I thought that somebody you were claiming
that someone else was claiming that I I'm actually lying by saying
that the information was fake, insinuating that it's real. So
that's where the mis
get hung up over whether you did or didn't lie or just intentionally
gave a fake one just proves that you you're obviously not confident
on this [__] argument, right? You're not comfortable
with your position. The fact that you're trying to get us stuck
in potholes like this what part am I not confident on? >> You
just made a clan whether the moral argument about whether you
do liar's wife or not. Wait, that or shared doc information as
if there's a meaningful moral distinction. >> Descriptive
that's a descriptive argu if we're if we're arguing whether or
not it classifies as doc. >> Uh he definitely wasn't intentional
of faking it. That's just >> we're just arguing what descriptive
thinkal not the moral value. >> Do you think that it was
morally okay? >> I think it was morally neutral. >> Dude,
you're such a debate pervert. This is so
now you're insinuating that you would disagree with the with
describing it as morally neutral. Um, it's totally totally morally
it's actually totally morally neutral. >> Argue for that
instead of doing like instead of doing like a lazy victory. >> I
think that revealing somebody's PI is only done with the intention
of directing possible harassment to them. There's no upside and
a huge potential downside. You cannot argue that doxing is morally
neutral. >> Okay. So your argument So your argument was
about potential harassment. That's why morally bad. That's why
let's take your definition of doxing. Let's take a cultal thing.
Let's take a misunderstand sometimes people clarifying why is
that wrong that seems to offend you I guess I don't know why
>> let's take your definition of doxing why is that wrong
>> um yeah here's the thing uh Becket told me about this
I actually didn't know about this but Becket told me about this
that Aiden had sort of been vague posting that he had the information
on Leo's wife on's wife that to me takes away any like question
of whether or not this was malicious right like he had like he
literally had the idea. He formed the idea to go and taunt this
guy with the information before posting it. It's like it's over
then. It's like it's obviously doxing. Sorry. It's like not even
a question.
>> Why is my definition of doxing wrong? >> No. No.
Why would it be immoral?
>> It can be immoral, right? Under >> Sorry. That
even goes for like even though maybe he threatened to call but
he had other information, other doc's information. It's like
I have the information on your wife. I'm trying to menace you
with it. and then he posts like publicly or sorry uh personally
identifiable information on the wife. It's like you're you're
menacing with that kind of information that you post that kind
of information in a place that's hostile to Leo and his wife
like Lio and his wife.
>> I identify as I'm utilitarian. I'm utilitarian. Um and
I think that um I think that uh if the if the act is going to
cause like net harm
>> dickers dickers is doing in like an offensive way. Okay.
Not not in like a defensive way to protect themselves, but an
offensive way. He's doing uh like Hutch faces right now. Like
Dickers is Aiden with like Aiden makes an argument,
>> He's doing like the He's doing the Hutch thing. He's
totally like over Aiden. >> If the act is going to cause
like >> you'll love to see it. >> Um then it would
be morally wrong. But I it's going to obviously once again depend
on the context, right?
>> I've made this argument before like I don't
So you don't think that doxing is inherently right? I don't inherently
assign a moral weight. Like doxing is just the doxing is just
the the term for the for like the act that's not going to carry
weight for me. >> Okay. So you reveal I what you're [__]
saying is
>> Yeah. Aiden's totally behind the like Aiden can't argue
this. This argument's over. He's he's almost doing more harm
to himself like by arguing this than he's going to even do with
the gokado stuff which is going to come later. Okay. This stuff's
like Tom Foolery level. This stuff's very rough. Um, Perry's
there now. Perry's the guy who leaked the the Gokado stuff earlier
on his stream. Uh, I can't Perry hasn't even started talking.
Aiden's like Aiden's like set himself on fire multiple times
already. And Perry has not stopped speak or sorry, started speaking
yet. He's essentially not
>> Crazy. You've given away Lio Comboy's personal information.
And you don't think the docking is >> I haven't given I
just like reposted some like uh some like I just upcom I just
screenshot. >> You just kind of like spread what you believe
to be doc information. Yeah, I sent I sent like a photo of some
troll YouTube channel into a group uh a group thing I'm in. >> No,
you didn't. Yeah, hundreds of people. How many people are in
IC right now, Aiden? >> It's like I think it's what uh
how many I don't know the exact like count. It's not hundreds.
That's a lot. >> It would be nice to know how you Okay,
you could like ballpark that and you >> I mean, let's be
real. I see. It's just [__] public. It doesn't matter
how many people are in a particular forum. It's the fact that
you given away that information that can then be
>> the fact that like there's more than five people in
there and as soon as you post it in there, like that could be
considered public. Like
it depends on if it's like a a close-knit circle, like a trusted
circle, maybe you could argue some of that information is in
there that like you're not going to publish. Like I'd say if
you posted something like a docs to like a five person group
chat and there's some
actual argument for I have you know a reasonable a reasonable
reason to do this like we we're trying to figure something out.
We're trying to do something. We're never going to publish this.
We know we're not going to harass this person right and then
somebody else publishes it. Maybe you got some argument but that's
not Icy. Ices is at least 100 people way more than 100 people
probably spread further care about >> Icy guys. Aiden never
kicks anyone out of ice. He trusts all of them so well so
>> Like you trust everyone in Icy to do anything with >> No,
but what's like the sarcastic dialogue that you're you're doing?
Nobody's ever claimed that I trust >> of you and wrong
of you to post the info >> Wait, sorry. Say one more time.
I didn't hear you. >> Well, the problem is that you know
you can't trust everyone in IC and hence you should not post
the info about >> Okay. When you say Okay. Okay. When you
say you can't trust. Okay. That's vague descriptor. If you're
arguing for that, >> he's obviously crying about the fact
that he's got kicked from icy. >> Trust them to do what
you can't trust. >> He's obviously crying about the fact
that he has been melted from icy. That's obviously what he's
talking about. >> Wait. Oh, dude. I know. I know you like
Li. You need to do like you're trying to do like a two. No, I
got it. I got you. >> Dickers is debating with faces as
up. I don't even know if stream. Okay. >> No, you're not.
You're you're just you're not like deeply rooting himself into
your way in a deeply psychotic way. You need a [__]
therapist
in the in the in the Discord as
>> he's kicked from Icy. Yeah, we read these DMs. We read
these DMs. This is Dude, the idea that Aiden, bro, Perry imitating
Aiden when he like shakes his head. Oh, dude. I literally said
I could tell Perry was going to do an imitation of Aiden like
running and then the the
Absolutely brutal stuff, man. Truly makes me >> As a whole,
there's 600 people. In Icy, there's 100 people. Why does 600
matter? >> None of them will do anything bad with that
info. >> Why is the Why does the total server count? Why
didn't include that? >> I mean, you can pick that up if
you want to. We just like move on with the >> That's actually
not relevant. You just include that to make everything seem more
cuz it's okay. It's okay.
But you >> for IC, Aiden has never had to remove people
from IC because they engage in bad behavior. And therefore, there
is no risk, no bad behavior through Aiden posting Leo Convoy's
wife in IC. That's Aiden's position.
>> When we say, by the way, >> like 100 people >> are
the deleted. I'll just check.
>> I'll be real. I thought ISU was way bigger than that.
That's Yeah, I thought ISU is way bigger than that. >> Are
the reposts of her her doc's information redacted? >> I
don't I know you just went through and deleted everything. >> I
did not go through and delete everything. I deleted one or two
>> No, you the original post of just me posting a picture
that you deleted that. I can I can go pull up the audit logs
if you want. >> It wasn't just me. It was several people.
Yeah, cuz we were trying to argue that like
people I don't know what you're trying to implicate me. people
delete like two messages >> because it wasn't just two
messages cuz I've gone back in the in the logs and check how
many times you got posted. >> Was it like a firing squad?
Were you all clicking like the delete button
Aiden, you can tell Aiden is just
>> for anything he can grapple on to right now. Several
messages got posted.
>> I think on my we're saying the original ones, the ones
I posted,
>> which are morally distinct from all the people who kept
on reposting it after the fact since yours kept on getting >> Some
woman's face. No one no one cares. >> People do care cuz
people people gave it several times. I can still see I think
7K reposting her information. I think I can see twice here that
it hasn't been
>> Why would he? >> Yeah.
Do anything bad with that info. >> I'm so sorry, man. >> Why
would 7K's information containing the docks of my boy's wife
get deleted? Are you serious? Discord if nothing else
with the reckless points cuz you know I'm right. What? You're
just like sitting doing like little >> um I have a feeling
that we could probably reasonably infer this is the current count
of Icy right now. Okay, I'm guessing we could probably infer
that one, some people might not even have the role have site
with like admin or something. Two, that this number would have
been a little higher before people were starting to get kicked.
Like at least Hellbent's been kicked, but I'm guessing other
people have been kicked too. Wouldn't be shocking. >> Unfunny
sarcastic whips every It's like really awkward. Okay, then just
walk and mute him.
>> If it's that much of a mental drain, then just like
reduce his off. >> No, it's not. I'm just addressing the
other person in the call. Hold on. What? >> I'll be real.
We got about 30 minutes left, okay?
And I don't know if you've ever I've there's a fantasy novel
that I really like, a fantasy series I really like, and it had
this problem, okay, where I know some crazy [__]
has to happen cuz I can see the pages running out and I know
crazy happens at the end, and I'm like, how do they even fit
the ending into this? There's like 30 minutes left and they're
not even talking about the Goat stuff yet. How How do we get
there? >> Wait, I'm addressing the other person. Yeah,
cuz that's bizarre. Why would you take issue with me addressing
the person that you voluntarily have in here that's talking?
Of course, I'm going to [__] acknowledge her. >> Okay,
I don't know why you're trying to dude. You're trying to sandbag
the conversation so [__] bad. >> No, I'm just
I'm address you have somebody in this call. >> I don't
know to be fair. You are >> back you up. I am acknowledging
that they exist because they are here by your own. What is the
issue? Noted. Nice. No issue. Noted. >> Are you like okay?
Like I feel like >> No issue. It's noted. Understand.
>> Are you like okay? >> Don't worry about me. >> So
what was your
call in? It's like I'm going to have a literal elephant in the
room just like pretend it's not here. I was like what? Obviously,
I'm gonna [__] god the guy. >> It's the fact
that you got on long [__] rants about him. That's
the thing that I'm talking about. But
>> I feel like Queman went to London with like a set of
tools like he's Dexter, okay? And he was ready to cut dickers
up into little pieces and put them in garbage bags and throw
them into the hems. Okay. And Aiden was mean to help and he was
like, "Whoa,
change of plans. We're sharpening these knives for Aiden now."
Okay. That's I'm I'm getting that feeling more and more that
it was like totally unreal. >> We move on from that. We're
going to move on from that. We got to move on from that. The
conversation dialogue >> What's your issue that we had?
Why did you want to call in? What do we disagree >> Nothing.
We ran over it. I We talked about the workplace stuff. >> Oh,
now we've ran over. Don't want to talk about it anymore. Okay.
Do you agree that you've searched for it? >> Um, it depends
on what you mean by truly hated as a person. No. Dickers is a
perfectly fine person. Dickers is a nice nice guy. Um, there
are elements there that are probably most people >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on. Let me just lay my See if you agree or
disagree with the recap. You searched for and published Lo Convoy's
private information, face, name, uh, occupation, and it was personally
identifiable information, right? People could use that for the
purposes of of harassment. >> Whose occupation did I publish?
>> Who do you [__] think? >> Who am I
talking about right now? >> Wait, I didn't pub I didn't
Wait, we already been Dude, are you Alzheimer's? Are you >> occupation?
Not workplace. Anybody had a job in your life, but these are
two distinct terms made up. And you have no >> It's not
made up cuz I know that in private you reiterated to me that
your occupation that you gave me is correct.
>> You can test it earlier. I mean people can go back.
This has all been dream. People can go back and see that you
were contesting about whether or not the workplace was correct.
You never challenged whether the occupation was correct and you've
doubled down several times in private that the occupation was
>> I know she's a doctorate. That's all. I know she's like
a doctor or something. >> Okay. You don't need to worry.
You don't need to be like anyone. >> No, he's Wait. That's
not Lio says that himself. Just do not give away any irrelevant
personal information about her. I don't give a [__]
I don't give a
>> Alban, be careful. Careful. >> Spoil. Wait. How
is that? >> Just refrain from giving unnecessary information
about just to be clear. Just to be clear, dickers cuz like this
is >> unless you're going to give me information to prove
that Li has also shared this information. I'm not going to take
it seriously. Obviously, unless you can unless you unless unless
you can show me Lio Convoy also sharing this information at this
point, it's unnecessary. It's unneeded and I'm asking you to
please stop. >> Okay. So, no. Got it. So, so whenever you
ever bring up a detail about anyone ever, I'm just going to stop
you from bringing it up until you can immediately prove that
you haven't gotten this information from some secret private
>> No, no, no. Because I believe that it is a I believe
this is doc's information and all the other [__]
you've been saying about
>> because you've all the information you've been given
about so far is doc.
This is the whole substance of the debate that you've been giving
docs information about this woman. So you've revealing other
information about her as well as
it's unnecessary. >> You're like, well, can you not because
this could potentially >> I don't know why you're trying
to bog down the conversation. I don't know if you're just spuring
or if you are trying to bog down the conversation. I'm just asking
you
like I can't even like bring up details. I'm running from the
allegations. You're ascertaining that they're you're asserting
that they're docs with no basis and making me unable to bring
them up in the argument. I'm okay. Does this help? Does this
help? Will this stop you spuring?
I am agnostic about whether that information has been shared
publicly. But given the fact that this whole given the fact this
whole conversation is being had about you sharing personally
information about this woman, I'm asking you to chill the [__]
out unless it's necessary. >> I'm not even saying it tomorrow.
I'm totally agnostic about whether it's not whether or not. I'm
asking you to stop.
>> But why would I stop if that's a defense against the
accusation being made against me? >> It's not a defense.
Why am I not rude? >> It's completely irrelevant. It's
irrelevant information. >> If the argument Hold on, hold
on. Tickers, you just said it's not. If the argument is that
I am leaking this person's occupation, which is doxing information,
meaning it was leaked without their consent by another party,
right? If I'm telling you that they voluntarily on a public platform,
LIO just tells people this. Okay. How would that not be a direct
defense against the accusation being led against? >> So,
you agree? So, you agree to defense? I'm saying if >> will
dickers take that super chat that says point out the Willy Mack
thing and point out that Aiden banned somebody from mist. >> If
that's true if that's true then that's fine. Like I said I am
I am I am >> such a weasel
I'm the loser. You're here justifying doxing's wife. Going back
again 10-minute conversation with go cat. Completely change your
position. As soon as somebody starts talking about it on live
stream, you're right back to your original position. You're being
dragged around by your ego. Don't call me the >> What is
she? I haven't you want to see our I you know look in the last
week I think I DM >> I mean goat has already confirmed
you had a private conversation. You've confirmed you've had a
private conversation and that's what led to you apologizing and
taking out joined her. No she has >> you're trying to run
away from that because you're trying to avoid the fact that you
already
thing just to be clear as well. Um you just conceded by the way
that you weren't allowing me to give an argument against an assertion
that you made against me. Uh if you disagree that all of a sudden
okay so you disagree that all so let's rerun it. I'd love to
do that. Okay. And so before you did this like weird like go
cat pivot about you having a private it wasn't private. It's
in like a general VC that like anyone can join. I join in to
chill. I ask you to like join to be able it's not it's not public.
There are no like serious public has no private server. You're
unable to demonstrate or argue. >> It's a private VC. You
got a private VC with gokado. >> Yeah. Okay. Okay. That's
like saying IC is private. Like it's like a V. Like we're all
in there. We're all on that call. Like >> uh so there's
like five people who have the role in goats. Okay. Go on. >> There's
five people in her server.
>> Go on. >> No. Five people that have perms to that
Discord server or five people that have perms to that Discord
channel. Um, >> dude.
Uh, yeah. Some content happened here. V B V B V B VV V V V V Victoria
akent
pop off that I had to cover. I've just like invested. So, we're
getting through this. Okay.
>> Where where you getting that information from? I don't
think that's true. >> It's also tragic that I probably
can't even catch up with the context. Basically, Aiden Underground,
Aiden
Projects setting his entire commentary like streaming career
on fire for no
Sort of Tom Furyesque. Okay. It's Tom Fulleresque. It's It's
really
some absolutely insane that it seems like everybody around him
has tried to get him to stop doing and he just refuses. He's
like the guy who's correct. He's going to prove everybody else
was wrong and he's sort of just repeatedly embarrassing himself
in this >> I'm saying, >> dude, the the arguments
are actually almost mechanically
the ex like onetoone transposed onto Tom's. Like when to Tom
Tom Tom would do and by the way Tom another massive Destiny fan
who copies all of his ways of arguing, right? Like doesn't like
thinks that's the best way to argue. It's like Tom trying to
bog the conversation down. Tom trying to like like uh like pivot
anywhere he can to to
like like not have the primary the core conversation. He tried
to like get into just he tried to genericize it. He wouldn't
want to talk about the actual allegation or what was actually
going on. He just tried to make everything generic. Uh, wait.
So, I like can't hit on women. It's Dude, it's like the same
mechanically. It's very bizarre. >> Surprise, I'm aware.
>> Okay. Well, I would love to hear where you were made
aware of that cuz I don't think that's true >> because
I am aware of five people that have access to that Discord chat.
>> Okay. So, you made it up. Um, so far I'm
>> Yeah. Back to the argument. >> So, to be clear,
so to be clear. Okay. We could rerun this again. You just completely
pulling [__] out of like thin air and not having
any evidence to substantial. Just go into your argument. >> That's
what I'm doing. Okay. Yeah. Cool. So, we can move on. Um, so
back to the argument itself, right? You claimed when I said you
were not allowing me to provide this argument to you reveal any
more information about this woman that information is irrelevant
and you're interrupting me. So to be >> so Dicker is literally
saying I don't have to I don't accuse you of doxing but like
obviously we're not going to go verify this woman's like info
on stream. I don't want to have this I don't want you to reveal
anything else on stream. You can't just keep revealing things
when our core argument is you're doxing this woman by revealing
this information. You can't say no I'm not. Here, look. I'll
reveal the information now. I am saying you're doxing her.
Please stop.
For my stream's sake, please stop. That's what Dicker is trying
to get him to do, right? He's like, I I'll I think Dickers is
basically implied like maybe not that he's retracting the doxing
allegation because there's other information, but he'll say like
even if you faked like this one piece of information, it's still
bad. You still made the threats beforehand. But like I will say
that I won't say that that was doxing on my stream. We could
just move on. and we figure it out later. >> You just lied
when you insinuated to everyone you were going to let me rerun
my argument cuz as I'm giving it to you, you're actively the
argument that we are having. I don't care about this little quibble,
dude. And I assure you, nobody else does either. We're explaining
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. The argument is the nature of the doxing
information that you're alleging that I had spread. I'm attempting
to invoke that occasion
reason for why I'm not allowed to ask you substantive I'm asking
you a substantive question. Of course that is >> The occupation
that you claimed that she worked as is that her real occupation
or do you believe that that is her real
>> Oh the wait the workplace? No. The
>> um no wait no >> wait the workplace. No that's
not what I'm asking. I'm saying the occupation. >> What
did I say she did for work? >> I thought you screen capped
this from a YouTube channel. Didn't you >> screen cap what
from a YouTube channel? >> Apparently you forgotten. >> Dickers.
This must be icy as well. I've made my opinions on this super
clear. Nothing you ever ever say is clear, you sneaky nons,
dude. Oh my goodness. Very funny stuff. Very funny stuff.
Very very very funny. >> And all of this stuff. >> No,
I I'm you know. Okay, so if I made this up, Dickers did. Do you
know what make makeup means? Like faking
>> So if so, the face was screenshotted from the channel,
but you don't need to do like what is it? This is like composition.
You're assuming what's part >> Go and search her. Go and
search her name in your [__] like fifth grade. go
and search her name in your Discord. >> Okay. So, just
to be clear. So, just to be clear, I screenshotted the face from
the YouTube channel. Can we agree on that? And then this other
information that you're invoking that we keep disputing, that's
made up, right? >> This is information that we keep on
disputing. Do you know her? Do you know that where she works?
I know you do cuz of what you told me. >> I don't know
where she works. No. If you're going to claim what she works
as, that was my L. That was my L. What she works as? What she
does for work? >> No. I know what degree she has. I don't
know what she does for work. No. I heard someone say she's a
>> You gave me that piece of you gave me I've DM'd you
the piece of information that I just sent you in DMs. Is that
true or not? Do you believe that to be >> That's not a
job. >> Of course that's a job.
>> Okay, you if you were working in Okay, so there's no
way we can argue
>> Aiden's prolific career as his his prolific career is
like terminally unemployed,
rearing its ugly head right now. Okay, this guy has never had
a job. This guy doesn't know what a job is.
And
dude, I'm guessing like
I'm I'm guessing she's got like a PhD. I'm guessing it's not
physicist. I'm guessing it's something like physicist that implies
you're a scientist that like Aiden thinks you wouldn't be employed
as a physicist. You'd have like some other title. I'm guessing
it's something like
>> You claim that I'm doc I could address this. You understand?
This is the equivalent of me saying she she knits sweaters, right,
Aiden? She knits sweaters. And you say, um, knitting sweaters
isn't a job. Obviously, this is not something that people do
in their pastime. This is not a hobby. This is something that
somebody does with the aid of a workplace and organization. Just
to be clear, just as a [__] you supposedly going
for your PhD, right? You understand that this specific task that
you've just described, the specific task that you've what? >> Go
ahead, Nicole. the specific task that you've just described is
involved in like every scientific field ranging things ranging
from psychology to um uh psychology to to music like it is like
you're describing you're describing a component you're describing
a component of work but this actually is in relation to a wide
variety of occupations >> you said that you you have a
PDF of examples of her work >> I do not
>> have you not read examples of her work >> no
Okay.
Directly contradicts what you told me in you know what she's
done for a degree. You know the areas she's published in. You
said that you read her.
Have you or have you not read her papers? >> We're going
to take a trip back to say that you said you did a trip back
to five says that you said that you did. >> Oh boy. How?
Oh no.
Oh no. Not a ride or die here. Not a ride or die. Well, I guess
Gokado is kind of like actually,
bro, Aiden has showed himself to be a lowquality male. Okay,
a low status male. What do women do to a low status male?
I This is not true. I don't actually believe this. Okay, they
in the gut. Dude, it's so up that she did this.
What is she supposed to do if she's li If he's lying?
Um, literally don't say anything. Literally don't say anything.
Maybe.
Literally just shut your computer off. Go for a walk. Pretend
that you don't have to uh like just just literally go for a walk.
She she didn't have to put him down like this.
Uh, it's possible she helps >> BECAUSE IT WAS [__]
I'm doing like the unhinged doxing troll. Explain. >> No,
you're not. This was in a private VC where everyone was chill.
We were calmed down. said this. >> This is
I I've never read them. Did you say it? What? What are you talking
about? Go Cattle comes in. Yeah, he did say it. Um I was doing
the unhinged doc I was doing the unhinged doxing thing. The meme.
The me the meme about unhinged later on I >> Hey Aiden,
what what unhinged doer are you imitating? Is it the same one
you've been imitating the entire debate? >> If you had
actually said that the uh the workplace that you gave was fake
>> so people know I said that you had read her papers.
I've never read her papers. Did I ever tell you any details of
the papers I allegedly read? >> Yeah, you did. You said
that you wanted to go in a similar field. >> Okay. What?
Okay. DM me the field. DM me the field that I said I wanted to
go >> And now you're reading it remembering that I'm right.
>> No, I don't even Is that what she I don't I don't think
that's what she >> Okay. Just FYI, when you said this,
this was not a joke. This was something you said calmly. >> Well,
that would be saying a little bit of trivia. >> I want
Okay. Can you provide some like substance? Like I feel like you've
just repeatedly made up premises in their so like can we have
some substance to work with falsifiable you know how to like
make an argument >> about what you said in a Discord VC.
No obviously not. >> So once again so this is why >> I've
got I've got though somebody else was in the Discord VC confirming
that that is what you said. >> No go. So if she wants to
call in and debate as well go ahead. Sure. >> If you want
to call in and debate your girlfriend about whether or not you
do life on boys. >> Not my girlfriend. I don't know what
your like weird obsession with my life >> If wants to uh
WhatsApp life what the [__] you talking >> if
wants to call in now. She absolutely >> She says she's
not debating.
>> Are you now going to call out Gut Cass for running?
>> Well, I don't know if she's You're claiming she's on
your side on this position. So, yeah, if she's affirming your
side, uh the like if she's affirming your argument, then sure.
Yeah, absolutely. If And then if you're going and using her,
>> is crashing out Jay's talk. He's prime for another call
in. I >> No, if he's talking about this, I don't
>> sorry, but dude, we're doing awesome stuff over here.
I can't actually address the person you're sourcing for
to your argument and then I can actually
>> slowing it down amplifies it the worst way. Ah >> address
the person you're sourcing for credibility then yes that is absolutely
running of course.
>> Okay.
Ah >> yeah. So she says that she's not debating. I mean
she's saying it publicly in chat. It's not it's not privately
in the end. >> Great evidence you're working with here
about what happened at a VC. I think the fact that a second person
is corroborating what you've said is actually better evidence
than what's said in VC. >> Can I address the witness, please?
>> You can if you'd like, but Goku says she doesn't want
to join the call.
>> Oh, weird. Weird. Your witness mean weird. Great. Great
witnesses. You >> What do you mean weird? Great. >> Dude,
it's I I'm starting to get why he wants sick offense. Okay. You
need you need a cult when you're going to argue like this. >> This
is some rough stuff, man. assist been rough the whole time. Myra,
wait, Myra, did you gift subs earlier in this stream, too? I
feel like you might have gifted subs. Yeah, you gifted subs eight
hours ago. Thank you for the other the the now 8 hours later,
five gifted again. Let's go. Thank you so much, Myra. I really
appreciate it. Yeah, 8 hours ago, five gifties. 8 hours later,
five more gifties.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
>> Oh, no. >> Since this is important, this is not
a woman that is on my side in this. In fact, she has a heavy
bias for you
>> what got you Sodnik? Are you unaware that Aiden Underground
has set himself on fire like in the most insane of ways? He basically
so just in case anybody's like rolling in now, Aiden basically
doxed like a guy he's been following for a while. Doxed this
guy's wife. Refused to admit that he was doxing this guy's wife.
Has now like basically gotten a private call where his friends
had to convince him, "Yeah, you did and you probably need to
like hold the L on this." And then finally he was like, "Yeah,
you're right." But finally he apparently accepted, okay, that
yeah, he [__] up. He probably needs to hold the L
on this. And then today it gets revealed that
by Perry that Aiden is been approaching this goat cat person
who's a woman who his content is kind of centered around for
a while or who he's defended contentwise and who he's like close
friends with and who apparently he has a crush on. He he had
a crush on her, asked her out, something along these lines. Okay.
And
and
that rattled him. He is trying to go and argue that actually.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I I did not dox.
I did not dox. He's like gone back on that position. And now
his his girlfriend who tried to convince him, sorry, uh the girl
the girl he wanted to date that apparently he was rejected by,
but I'm not sure about that yet. She is saying, well, actually,
you did, you know, agree to a whole bunch of the things we're
saying. You you did say that you knew this information about
her. You you you're kind of lying in this debate right now with
Dickers attempted girlfriend. Oh, boy. >> Can you substantiate
that? Do we really want to go into the the details of between
you and >> Goat? Yeah, there's there's there's no there's
no detail.
>> All I'll say is guys, goth girls, not even once. Okay.
>> Goth girls, not even one. Goth goth adjacent girls not
even one time. Okay? Never ever ever ever.
>> listen, right?
>> I She was more goth in the other video I pulled up.
I thought it was when I clicked. Did you tell Goku that you love
No.
Oh, no. No.
No. Aiden, no.
>> You love that. >> There's no details, right? I
I guys keep >> Did you tell Goku that you love that? >> Yes.
And I said it to you, too.
Have you guys been on I don't know an emotionally complicated
>> sleepy time PC situation ship you wait you and those
you and those jar sleepy time VCs >> have you guys been
on I don't know an emotionally complicated
>> I've never I've never situationship answer the question
honestly no there's no stickers
I I'm I'm I'm >> You just said that you were >> Oh
he saying he was trolling now he was he was trolling Also, the
one HP voice is pretty rough. Okay, the one HP voice is tough.
You're not looking good with the one HP >> with this being
discussed about why she's on your side rather than mine. >> When
did I say I wasn't acting? >> Who would you say has had
a more intimately uh a more emotionally intimate relationship
with Gokau?
You or >> Dude, why did he say it like that? Yo, why he
say it like that? What the >> Can you show your DMs with
Goata?
Can you show your cat? >> That's valid. >> I'll show
you mine if you show me yours. >> Wait, why would Yeah,
absolutely.
>> Okay, we can leak. Okay, go on then. >> Dude,
I feel like I feel like Aiden's DMs. He's going to go like, "Yeah,
you can look at our DMs." And it's going to be nothing but call
logs. There's going to be no DMs. There's going to be call logs
only and there'll be like super long call logs. And he's going
to go, "Look, you can't prove anything. I can see it. I can see
the vision already." You think that >> You think that Goat
Kata has had a similarly emotionally intimate relationship with
me as she has with >> This is the contention. >> We
can't see your I wouldn't know enough to attest to that. I need
to see the DMs. I've heard whis. >> Have you had an above
average emotionally intimate relationship with >> I'd say
it's average.
>> Okay. Would you say that you have a emotionally intimate
relationship with goat as you do with like many other
>> It's kind of like do you tell many people that you love
them? I when did I say that I what?
>> Apparently you've told Gakato and you said this earlier
that you love her. Do you do that to many people? >> Wait,
when we just I just told you I was joking and then recclarify.
Anyone could rewind the VOD. I just reclarified I've not said
that >> cuz apparently you said you cuz you you correctly
said that you've told me as
>> Yeah. No, that was a joke and then I clarified immediately.
>> UH
NO HELP. STOP. The leaks HAVE TO STOP. THEY HAVE TO SOMEBODY
HAS to Somebody has to stop stabbing this guy in the back. Caesar
has enough daggers in his back. Help,
please. It's It's the eyes of March in January.
No.
Is this new information or did Wait, Hellbent, is that new information?
Have you said that somewhere? Is Is Queen aware of that or are
these people all broadly aware of that? Has that I don't even
know. Is that public? Dude, this is
>> And you don't It was not a joke. That really happened.
>> Right after I told you that I loved you. I've not told
you that I loved you. I've not told Goat that. >> I've
just No, you've told me right after that you love Goat.
>> What? Now wait that you've now just shifted the goalpost.
>> What? No, I'm asking about your relationship with Goat
versus my relationship with Goat.
>> The solid answer to the initial goalpost that you had
said, right? You're now >> Can we see the DMs with Goat?
I can see the entire bait if you do. >> Sure. Are we getting
like a Wait, hold on, hold on, hold on. You first. >> What?
You're the one who who issued the >> No, it's courteous.
It's because you asked me a question first and I had another
question, but I answered yours >> So, it's courteous considering
I've now asked for you to provide the burden in this instance
for you. >> Hashem, Hashem, protect me. Hashem, please,
if you could hear me, Hashem,
Aiden hears through divine providence the URL
redact.dev.
He's He's saved. He's saved.
The protector of the people's privacy. Okay. Redact.dev.
Um, okay. Sure. >> Oh, by the way, um, any of the chatters
who want to refute, uh, anything that I've stated in the course
this, you can call into my streams. I will be live >> Let's
just go for maybe the last two months. Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. >> I'll be seeing you, Tyrone, by
real quick. Real quick, real quick. Uh, Tyrone 9000
will be debating me tomorrow because he disagrees. And in this
community, when you disagree, you debate. So, I am looking forward
to whatever time. >> I feel so uh listen, I think Aiden,
if Aiden can beat Tyrone 9,000 in this debate, I really think
he's got it turned around, guys. All he's got to do, Tyrone 9000,
aka the first domino on his way back to the top, baby. Tyrone
9000's going down. Let's go. Let's go. Hold up. We had a dicker's
message back here. Oh, whoops. Uh, Aiden painted himself into
this corner. He could have just admitted she was she would be
biased in his favor. I should have picked up what he was putting
down here. I thought this has been leaked by Perry and already
confirmed.
Um, well, it was Dickers. I think they're going to lie to you
and tell you it wasn't confirmed because they denied it. But
I went over the Perry VOD and unfortunately for Aiden,
basically Perry sort of leaks this this whole idea and
and
goat dot dot dotson leaves the chat. She leaves and then
god bless him that he is soul skitty comes in and starts tearing
into Perry. And in my mind, that immediately confirms that Perry
is like 95% on the money. Like they they could say that that's
not proof. To me, I'm sorry. When when Soul Skippy comes in and
starts talking about what a piece of Perry is, you're so up for
violating somebody's privacy like this. He's totally confirming
that this is like something that happened. And then eventually
a little bit later, Soul Skippy come back and goes, "Actually,
you're lying." And and Goka, like 45 minutes, an hour later,
they come back. You're actually lying. You're lying. Why are
you lying, Perry? And it's like, dude, you guys gave the game
away, man. I'm sorry. You guys could have responded in the moment
if you wanted to, and you didn't. You would have, if this was
just totally made up, they would have gone, "That's totally fake.
What the [__] are you talking about?" And they did
not. They didn't at all. >> Bad. I'm sorry. Go. I know
that you've just deleted those messages.
I've got a Discord Discord client that allows me to capture them.
I'm so sorry. They are going to be shown. Okay. >> Wait,
wait. Why? Why? I I actually don't know why. Why did Dickers
Wait, she didn't want some of those messages
That's I didn't scroll through. >> Is he gonna post this?
>> Uh last few months on mine. Okay, cool. >> Just
wait. Oh, please tell me. Please tell. Oh no. >> Are we
going to send them at the same
>> Dude, what are these gonna be? I'm so dude the idea.
Okay, if you didn't catch it, Dickers is literally saying, "Hey,
goat. I know that you just deleted a bunch of stuff. Uh, that's
going to be in there." Just so you know, >> I'll scroll
through and then you send me screenshots. Yeah. >> What
is it going to be? What is it going to be?
>> Oh, okay. The H3
mod here, >> you know, cuz Bob is involved in this.
>> Oh, she's evil. OH MY GOD, she's evil.
Oh my god, she's evil. What the
What the
Oh my god. Let Perion. Let Perion. LET P OH, OKAY. NO,
this is By the way, if you were wondering where Queenman went.
Oh, actually, I need to hold up. That's where it is. Okay, bro.
When this dude,
what my voice is cracking now. Holy [__]
When when you're like Aiden and you've like confessed your love
to a bunch of your friends about this woman and she's in the
DMs of the guy who is your career talking about the guy who's
tag team your career with him. Let him in. Let him in. Let him
in. Let him in. Let him in.
That's diabolical.
Oh my god. Holy [__]
Oh, there's like it's wrapped back around. She's like the female
version of Perry. That's so evil. like wraps back around to just
being awesome again somehow. Okay, that's so crazy to me. Holy
[__]
There's just no way. >> Actually, you make a very good
point. Wait a minute. Wait a second.
>> This is really where we're going with >> While
we're here and and this is going to seem like a pivot, but I
love >> This is absolutely a pivot, FYI. >> I love
to I just I just I I feel like it would hurt. You're talking
about this was if we're going to start this, okay, this was about
character evidence about whether goat Kat would be on your side
or mine. Are we getting that goat cat? Are we getting those goat
cat? >> Going to we're just going to go ahead and dox.
You know, one wasn't enough. We're going to dox another totally
innocent. Let's go.
>> Okay. Nice. >> I might have shown that [__]
on the stream, too, so it's not that big a deal. But dude, does
gokado send Aiden content like this to cover?
>> Yeah. Hold on. >> Wait, hold on. We didn't see
all of those. Hold on.
>> Let Perry and Le Perry. We didn't see these before.
He's in the waiting room. He's in the waiting room. >> Dude,
she was excit Dude, she was so excited for the Aiden. The death
of Aiden was like so high up on her priority list. Dude, I didn't
know it got that bad. Oh my goodness.
>> Hold on.
Sorry. Go ahead. >> Oh, I did see some of these messages
after the fact. Was this in Que's chat? She was look at Queen's
after
um Goat Kat, did he ask you out or are uh and get a no? And she
says
sad face.
But is that her with the underscore? I actually don't know. Was
that her with the underscore? I don't have it up here.
>> you piece of [__] Let's find the missing
Tanuki footage.
That was the very excited reaction. I like that. >> What
did Kathy do? Wait, I pulled this up on stream, right? Yeah,
I did. Okay, those DMs were Kathy impersonating Kokado. Oh, thank
God.
Oh, thank God. Oh, thank God. I still feel like reacting the
same way. I feel like,
Okay. No, thank God. Oh, thank God. I legitimately am so happy
to hear that cuz I was I was unironically
those DMs were DMs with Clover Cutie. Yeah. Okay. I don't even
know who the [__] that is. I don't I don't Dude,
I'm just happy to hear that those were fake
cuz like
unironically if that if those were real
would be like, "Okay, you all have to back off of Aiden now."
Cuz like legitimately if he was actually in love with this woman
and that's what she was doing, I would be like we're all willingness
check on Aiden immediately. I dude, holy
dude, I've never seen something more evil than that. That was
that would have been so crazy. >> Oh, thank god that was
just Kathy. >> Okay, we're back. >> Oh my goodness.
Okay, so >> did you find the missing Tanuka? >> Here
we are. She says Aiden is threatening.
He says he's going to do it if you don't join VC. That was January
>> Wait, shouldn't that been obvious to Dickers when Kathy
is sending all of the H3 obsessed to Dickers?
Now that I'm like putting it back together, how do you not know
that Go Cattle hadn't sent you all of this
That I actually I would never make that mistake. I don't know
how Dickers made that mistake. He must have seen the same thing
I did. That absolutely delicious
let Perry in, let Perry in. That's so funny. Dickers do for sure.
Maybe, maybe, maybe. Dude, I just I'm psyched. I had that feeling
for two seconds. I
I saw true evil and it delighted me. Okay. I've never I've never
felt more alive than seeing true evil, witnessing true evil,
and then now I just know that it didn't exist. So, I got the
I got the absolute thrill of it and none of the emotional or
like moral baggage that comes with it. Okay. So, we got the best
of all worlds. Oh, we're winning. >> And then her conversation
with Tactical >> Oh, what the go back >> and then
her conversation with Tactical
>> We're good. We're good. And that takes us up to November.
Nice. Anyway, >> okay. Um, so, so since you I I'd like
to ask I'd like to use my um my mirror card since we're each
allowed to use one logical fallacy adopted by the opponent in
the course of the argument to >> Dude, this is so
>> show your DMs with Goat Kau. Wait, are
>> talking about
>> this is why kick is better sometimes because the only
response there is to tell Aiden to stop being an Fs slur and
on YouTube I do believe that could get you banned. Okay, on kick
you got a shot. On kick it could get you banned possibly, but
you got a shot at least. Like the response to Aiden there is
stop being a whiny f slur. Like just go >> about whether
goat kata was on your side or mine. She's obviously on yours.
You've told me that. You've told her
>> that you love her or at the very least that you do.
>> I've never said that. I >> apparently you've said
to Perry that you're having a conversation with her on New Year's
Eve as well, saying that you're trying to confess her your love
for her. >> Do you think that you have an particularly
intimate relationship with
>> No. No. Wait. What did I say to Perry?
>> Okay. Do you think that you have an emotionally intimate
relationship with
would be on your side in this or on my side? Can I can I ask
you an honest
>> you can answer my question. >> Yeah. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Okay. I like her. Yes. Can I But can I ask you an honest
>> Why did his voice go up more than >> Yes. Yes.
Yes. Okay. I like her. Yes. Can I But
>> yes. Yes. Yes. I like her. Yes. >> Can I ask you
an honest question? >> Oh, right. And she likes you. Right.
Cuz it's not about It's not ne about your feelings about her.
It's about her feelings about you. >> But like but like
when we're getting drunk Hold on. This like I actually >> Does
she like you in return? >> I want to have a heart to heart.
No. Yes. I want No. No. No. Okay. I want to have a heartto-he
heart with you real >> Oh, that's not a homie play right
there. That's not a homie play right there. Uh, what can I ask?
Quick question for Dickers. If he's still in the audience right
now,
what was what was served by making that point? I actually don't
know except Aiden's being an annoying epsler right now and you
heard him. I actually don't know what you're trying to argue
with that. Actually, do you did she like you back? Critical critical
for us to figure out if she likes you back. >> If we're
now talking about conversations that I was saying to people on
new like if I was drunk and like talking to you about like I
don't know someone I was interested in or whatever. Isn't that
like a really weird move to go and like air out on stream?
>> Well, that's already public.
>> you said that previously.
>> You said that in this conversation, but you said it
to her and you said it to No, you're now. Okay, you can move
it. >> Wait, hold on. I do think Wait, Aiden might have
a point here, right? How's the stream still going? Cuz some crazy
happened. Okay, it's all about Gokat's disposition towards Aiden
and I. Wait, but then he answers no. >> People can roll
it back. You said that. >> Wait, they can. He's going to
be wrong. I will give you nod $100
USD. 100 USD and and I will match it. I'll match it. Okay. Are
you in on this bet? You'll match it with yourself. >> yeah,
let's set the >> I also think >> Hold on. >> I
also think we had a good idea that she was not like you're literally
looking at logs where she's taking your side. It seems like
I I would just say, okay, it's not quite as evil as what I thought.
But I would I would say
this is not a ride or die for Aiden, okay, by any means.
>> Not even
>> this is so embarrassing. >> Okay. No, no, no.
It's a No, it's this >> this is a completely tangential
argument as you've been doing the entire time to distract from
what we're actually here to talk about. >> Okay, this is
his thing. You'll start making an >> Aiden. Aiden has totally
refused to engage with the substance of the argument the entire
time. >> I say and then when I go
>> when I respond, you're like, "This is pedant. It's tang."
It's like you you actually like initiated the dialogue.
>> Go ahead.
>> Oh, yeah. Okay. So, $100, right? If anyone can find
me saying admitting previously on this stream to telling Dickers
that I told Goat Cado that I loved her. Okay. $100 if someone
can find me admitting that before
>> Oh, yeah. Sorry. It's It's Perry who leaks it, right?
It's Perry who leaks it and maybe Wait, hold on. >> Makes
the claim that I did on this stream. Okay.
Um, Perry Perry leaked it. That's how it came about. Does Aiden
know that? Sometimes Aiden doesn't know that. Doesn't keep track
of the stuff as much as you think. >> And Dickers and Dickers,
since you're confident on this, saying anyone can rewind. Will
you publicly apologize to me and give me all of your earnings
for this stream so that I can then go take it, print it out,
wipe my ass with it, and burn it while making you watch?
Is that is that like a Is that rich kid talk? Like was that basically
him just doing a whole long-winded thing to go you're poor?
Did he just did he literally just go you're poor? Was that the
argument? Um I'm always going to stay winning cuz you're poor.
Hey dickers, if you thought about the fact that you're a poor,
you're like literally a parole. You're literally a pleb. You
loser. >> No, but I thought you were confident. >> So
what did you want to call in about >> I thought we were
talking about the doxing of Liar Convoy's wife. We got to go
here. Wait, but I thought you were. Okay, I'll up it. Participate
in the bet. I'll I'll make it 200. 200. >> Goat was making
comments to Gilded Poo. Ain't no way I should reach out to this
person to have them on stream. I I need to I feel like I need
to interview this person. This is like the first person I felt
like in a long time where I'm like, dude, I actually want to
talk to this person. I actually want to like I need to know more.
I need I need more information.
We'll see. We'll see what happens. No.
>> Are we talking about Li Convoy's wife or we going to
get bogged down in this? >> just talking about how anyone
can rewind the bot and
>> Yeah. So, so this is like how Weasel operates. He'll
start an argument. He knows he can't finish it. So then he'll
go and like desperately try to [__] on when he realizes
he's like completely [__] wrong. >> Mhm. You've
given you've given bounties before and you've paid people in
[__] Zim
Zimbabwean dollars. So I'm not going to NA agreement that you
were trying to like but out
people finding clips or whatever the situation you're referencing
that was because I didn't specify currency. >> You're weasling
out showing the DMs by the way. If you want to talk about >> United
States dollars United States >> you agreed to show your
DMs with gok did you not? >> Wait can I'll answer that
question. >> You did for the last 3 months. I mean this
is a new pivot that you've gone like on a new branch of conversation.
You going to show your DMs with goat or not? That was obvious.
agreed that she she has a more intimate relationship with you
than she has with me. >> Accepted that.
>> Okay. Right. So, we've accepted that participate in
bed. Are you going to >> This takes us from
originally talking about a conversation about my convoy's wife's
occupation.
Okay. And then go
about she agreed that you had talked about details of that in
VC and then we got into
>> as long as I as long as I just keep saying you're running
I you're dialogue where we talking about who is more reliable
or she seems like she's taking her side.
>> Aiden's about to figure out like very tragically that
VCs okay direct calls do not get deleted from >> just all
what like testimonial copy
>> I argue she's biased in your direction. $300 USD. >> All
right. Yeah, I'm not insane in this. Dude, do you want to argue
about the liar combo doc? You literally said you said not me,
by the way. Anyone, >> you're still not showing DMs that
you agreed to do earlier before you started going down this
>> rabbit hole where you're trying to like issue bets.
Show the DMs.
>> I wait. I'm telling you I like this person. It is obviously
a ridiculous. >> Okay, so now you're not showing the DMs
>> Talk about being Weasly. Talk about being Weasly. Obviously,
Goat has a more like emotionally intimate relationship with you
than just with me.
Talking about being Weasley. Talking about being dishonest than
conversations. Get [__] real, dude. I do feel like
uh
I feel like Dickers did give him a chance. Okay. Dickers was
like and it's probably he might have even borded on too nice
after a certain point in the conversation trying not to get this
guy like killed and this guy just wanted to get I don't know
I don't know what to say man came with the please sign for some
reason I don't know weasly going to do some [__]
cringe bet with you >> stickers stickers if I actually
I swear to God if I have to remind you of why do why did you
ask me to show the DMs to prove what point >> because you
asked me to show my DMs with >> yeah But what was the point
that you were attempting to?
>> He conceded the point, but it's like,
okay, we agreed to a mutual. So Aiden is is going to be correct
here kind of, but he's going to fail on like basically there
were two agreements made. What or sorry, two two arguments being
had,
an argument and an agreement. So the argument was whether or
not Goat had a more of an emotional attachment to Aiden or Dickers.
The obvious the obvious answer was Aiden. She has more of an
attachment to Aiden and Aiden was arguing that and basically
Dicker showed the DMs and then Aiden conceded and but it was
basically imagine it's like poker. They both agreed to like show
their cards and Aiden's trying to get away without showing his
cards right now. He's like, "Oh no, I lost." And he's trying
to like throw his cards in. It's like, "No, no, no, no, no. You
got to show me your cards."
And he's like, "No, I I just agree. I lost. No, you can have
the You can have all the chips in the pot. You can have all the
chips in the pot. I just don't want to show my cards." And it's
like, "That's not how the game works." Okay, that's not You made
me violate my privacy. You made me show DMs.
Why are they fighting over some goth girl? Um, they're not. They're
not. They're not. They're not. They're not. That was I don't
think Dickers is involved with this person at all. They're not
fighting over her. Aiden is got a
possibly unrequited thing going on. >> I was What? That
my >> You were obviously lying about the fact that I don't
know. Maybe me and go have an equally uh intimate relationship
than you and go. That was the point. >> Yes. Yeah. Agree.
Agree. Agree. So that's why I needed to show the DMs. So I've
already accepted. I've already accepted that. >> Yeah.
Exactly. And you knew all along that you had a more emotionally
more a more emotionally
intensive relationship with
obviously you know that you're loveydvey with goat Kau. And then
you're lying about that. You're lying about that. being intentionally
obsinant to be able to run away from the core substance of the
argument. This is the thing you're doing this entire conversation
has been tangent after tangent after tangent after
>> so I've learned something. Okay. And I might I might
even bass boost my mic based on this.
Uh Aiden has a critical defect that Destiny used to have and
has kind of rectified through bass boosting his as well and and
just the general voice training. Okay. Um
that is if you have a high pitch voice you're ining debates.
Okay. Because if you want to if you want to filibuster and you
want to talk over people when you have a high frequency voice
you can't do it. It gets totally drowned out by anybody with
a bassier voice. This is why this is Sunday's biggest strength.
Okay. You get that like bassy tenor going and people cannot compete
with that. You don't even have to yell. You just got to you could
just drop your voice down. You just calmly speak through things
with your voice and it will cut through that high-pitch whining.
Okay, we learned this from that same You remember there's that
one black guy who debated Erdite on TikTok and she was trying
to like spur over him and he just calmly kept restating his points.
He's like, "You're deflecting from this and you're trying to
like you're deflecting from this right now and it's very obvious
that you're running away and and here's like what my argument
was and here's what your argument is and you can't." And she
was like trying to like scream over him and she just couldn't.
She just couldn't overpower that deep that deep bassy voice.
Okay, that tenor.
And Dickers, you know, while not having a tenor necessarily,
has a far deeper voice than Aiden. And Aiden just kind of I you
can't even hear him over Dickers. sper after conversation sping.
I'm directly addressing your arguments. When have I ever brought
up something that complet Okay, so everything that I've brought
up, I know you do this thing and I want people to be aware of
it. He'll start an argument or he'll refute something and then
you go and attack that and you go and start an argument about
that and he'll all of a sudden do this. Oh, you're getting fixated
on this. It's like, no, you thought that it was important enough
to start this. >> You're intentionally branching like on
off onto like tangential topics that arrive from the core substance.
These were all in direct response to your statements. Can't invoke
it and then decide it's irrelevant when the opponent is providing
a reputation. That's how >> I don't know. I don't know
if it's cuz you're a or ADHD and you're getting hyperfixated
or what, Eden, but you are moving away from the core substance.
>> Pursuing you're pursuing or degrad.
Yes. When the opponent is presenting a >> What was that?
You're talking about like what? I'm leaking stuff about you and
go. What the was that, dude? >> How is that a leak? People
know. Wait, how is that a leak? >> What? What's the relevance
of that at >> Wait, no. Okay, you just claimed that was
a leak. That was not a leak. Said multiple times that you were
working with AI and >> Yeah. What's the relevance of that
at >> Okay. Because I'm making it it's I'm making an insult
against you. It's a jab. You've just claimed it is a it's a leak.
Do you want to now walk back that >> Okay. No, ma'am. Would
you like to walk back the claim? Yes or no? You just made the
claim. >> I'm not 100% about what you said. Okay. So, I'm
not going to get fixated on
>> I'm going to let it go. I can't remember exactly what
you just said. >> So, I'm going to let it go. >> You
forgot. You're No, no, you're not going to let it go. You're
going to >> I'm not aware I'm not aware of the particular.
So, I'm not going to argue over it. If I feel as though you've
leaked information, I'm not going to going to argue over what
you did or did not say. Obviously, you're asking what >> I
have no idea what he means working with it. I have no idea. >> I'm
not sure if you're being honest or dishonest right now. So, I'm
saying I'm going to let it go. >> Okay. So, you've asserted
that I've leaked some private information about your life. You
You're not able >> said that I'm going to let go. It's
fine. I'm going to be ambivalent about it. I'm not going to obviously
let it go. You've realized now that there wasn't a leak, but
you don't want to admit your is your >> I legitimately
don't Oh, Aiden alluded to what Dickers is. Uh
oh, I by saying Dickers is in his PhD or was thinking about going
for his PhD. One of the two. I think I knew that.
I've known some of this stuff, but I don't know if it's I assume
it's public.
Like I think I think I know what he did undergrad in.
I thought I I thought I was told, "Oh, PhD in AI." Wait, that
wouldn't make sense with what his
what? Oh, that doesn't make any sense to me. I immediately thought
Aiden had had leaked something extra I said to him IRL. Oh, I
didn't even catch that, man. But I'll be honest, I'm almost I'm
12 and a half hours,
right? >> I will say somewhere after the 6 hour point,
my brain turned on. So, that was nice. It was like my brain was
like, "Oh, so you're not going to sleep then, so I have to turn
back on." Okay. Okay. The first like 3 hours, four hours of this
stream, absolute trash.
After four or five hours, okay, brain brain turned on. It's like
a life or death situation.
Oh, then I second guessed it. So, I wanted to move on. I see.
I see. Got it. >> Yeah, that's true. Can we go back to
talking about how you do lyrici
clip? That's why every bad moment on your streaming
by your tangential things
unrelated. Just want to point out that a keeps on doing this
again and again and again. Can we go back to talking about how
you do Slayer Convoy's wife? Aiden, >> what was Okay, now
you're pivoting. Okay, we've already been >> Imagine you
join a debate like an abortion debate. Okay,
you join an abortion debate. You're like, "Okay, we finished
discussing how I argue about this one metaethical position. Can
we get back to talking about whether abortion is right or wrong?"
And they're like, "Oh, now you're pivoting." It's like, "No,
the whole point of this entire conversation was this one thing.
>> Pivoting. This is the original conversation we were
having. >> Get back to the conversation. >> If you're
not, I'm going to end the >> What was the leak? >> I've
already said that I'm not going to litigate what information
that I do or don't think you leaked. I'm going to let it go.
>> What was the leak? >> Does anybody know said that
I'm not going to do that? The only reason why you're trying to
press on this particular point is because I've said >> we're
not going to get bogged down in this, Aiden. I've made myself
incredibly clear. You're not going to keep on screaming. I'm
not going to litigate whether or not you did leak something cuz
I'm not sure exactly what you said. And so >> and so having
that conversation would be disclosing what I thought you said,
>> but I've already said I'm happy to be ambivalent about
this topic. And so we can go back to the original >> I
don't tell I don't no because even when we were doing the original
conversation when I was invoking that a claim that would defend
the assertion a claim that is relevant.
So you don't want to have the conversation going back to the
original
>> So, you don't want to have the >> Just to be clear,
just to be clear, you down on several points.
>> uh to resolve this, I need to ask Aiden, did you leak
that I redacted? Redacted. Redacted. Oh, so it's the same problem.
Um he calls it to Queen towards the end after queen finishes
watching Dickers. Goes back to Perry to fish Perry stream. I
see, dude.
Um Oh, I said something I was going to point out and now I lost
it.
Um, yeah, I lost it. We're going to keep >> Don't provide
a solid concession. You never provide a concession conversation.
>> You never provide a solid concession. >> You don't
want to have the conversation. >> No, I
>> You see, your problem, Dickers, is that you never provide
a solid concession. You literally won't concede even when you're
wrong. That's your problem. Okay. It's actually So, this guy
is like totally brain. That's just a crazy thing to say after
what we witnessed. I just want you to answer the question. There's
this little hump I want to get over. >> Yeah. Go ahead.
>> You to actually like argue for it or admit you're wrong.
>> Go ahead. >> Yeah. So, you've asserted that I've
leaked something.
If we don't get bogged down in that. >> Okay. Probably
required.
>> Probably require I'm sorry. It's >> It would literally
just be that for like hours and hours and hours. I've already
given him what I think is a perfectly justifiable reason. I mean,
Dickers could have just conceded that.
Honestly, he could have just said, "Oh, I [__] up
with this allegation. I misunderstood." And to litigate it now,
I think we'd have to go into details that I don't want on stream,
right? I think he kind of said that. You just said it in a way
that like I'm letting it go where that implies
I think he needed something some like minor concession. Okay.
I want to just see if a call's in here. I want to see what this
looks like. Okay. Give me a second.
It's right here somewhere.
has finished some of his Perry stream.
>> So we have this photo here before before he goes back
to the Perry thing. Very quick call in but very funny. Uhah,
he calls into Queen towards the end after queen finishes watch
back to Perry. >> That picture is
I think
>> Does he have his overlay up? I don't see I don't see
an Aiden call in here
but he might not have his overlay up. So >> I might if
I message you in the early afternoon then maybe I can but
all right man unfortunate I really hope you can play around it
around it. That's what I'll say.
>> Okay. Is it before or after the Perry call in? Ben sent
you a time stamp. Where? Wait. Hold on. Send me a
Oh, okay. I got a time stamp here. >> Good one, man. Good
one. You're in the waiting room, bro.
What do you mean? Oh, good one, man. Good one. You're in the
waiting room, >> Yeah. So, um I'm I'm assuming you've taken
a solid position in denounced stickers. Obvious lie that I leaked
information that he's up on his past
>> I don't know what he's referring to and I would have
to wait to find out.
>> Okay. All right. So, we're going to fence it for now.
Got it. Got it. Okay.
>> Wait. On past streams, would this be the the PhD something
like this? >> Yeah. Do you Somebody said I was like crashing
out. Is there like a I just >> Queen I'm not crashing out
right he wouldn't say I'm crashing out I'm not crashing out right
tell me I'm not
>> oh I don't know I feel like dude queen got to be so
torn here between
just with this guy giving me a little hope to keep it going and
knowing that everybody's going to see this that this is going
to be in public and that
that um that he probably just has to be honest and say no you're
totally crashing out I think you to reevaluate entirely. I I
actually don't know.
I He's got to say you're crashed out entirely. Like it's actually
totally fine. You are. You're lost. You've lost. You need to
check. >> The criticism is of me like responding to somebody.
>> That's That's >> Dude, it's like Yeah, that is
the friend thing to do. That is the friend thing to do. Okay.
hold on. I do want to I want to >> The thing is he's going
to hate me for doing that. got all this food given to >> Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> But yeah, that's the that's the Aiden situation. I think
Aiden's actually a complete and total loser. >> I gota
I got to hear it. >> Sorry, I hit my foot again. That really
hurt just now, guys. I think he's a complete and total loser.
I actually I really do. I really do. Um,
>> Is it a joint? I honestly I'm tempted to not let him
I'm tempted to just not let him call in. Yeah, cuz the thing
is he's going to hate me for doing that, but he's drunk and very
clearly
very upset. And we're just moving on to, you know, talking about
funny stuff now. You know, let him in the content, dude.
Let him spiral. See, you guys literally know like >> he
did drop the call,
guys. Literally know.
I'm looking. I'm looking,
>> dude. Looking. I'm looking. He's in the waiting room
or something. >> Let Aiden speak his truth. >> Do
I Do I do the right thing?
I feel like Quimman ended his stream and then he went and talked
to Aiden privately and tried to set him straight. >> An
adult. He's like 20, dude. What? Come on.
Okay, we're gonna We're gonna be >> This is This is all
a performance right here. Okay,
>> Aiden, no one's running from you right now, bro.
>> He He doesn't.
>> Hold on.
>> He How do I explain this? It's much better if Dickers
is the villain. Okay. It's much better if Dickers is the one
who killed Aiden. Why is Why does Queen Why does Queen doesn't
want that? Queen doesn't want to know Queen doesn't want to be
known for that.
It's much better this way. It's much better this way. Okay, everyone
killed Aiden. No, they didn't. Hey, then what do you want to
say? We're We're going to do one brief
question and then
we're not going to let this go on. Okay. Aiden, figure out your
>> Waiting room where nobody can speak.
Got to move to a mute. >> Oh, wait. Cuz you're in the waiting
>> What do you mean? Oh, >> good one, man. Good one.
>> You're in the waiting room, bro. >> Yeah. So,
um I'm I'm assuming you've taken a solid position and denounced
Kicker's obvious lie that I leaked information that he's up on
his past
>> I don't know. Oh, >> what he's referring to and
I would have >> I see. >> Wait to find out.
>> Okay. All right. So, we're going to fence it for now.
Got it. Got him. Okay. >> They all stabbed him. Uh, a lot
of people did him.
Okay. A lot of people did them. It was Listen, eyes of March
in January was accurate. Okay. >> I was just curious. Um,
yeah. Do you Somebody said I was like crashing out. Is there
like a I just wondering like what the criticism is of me like
responding to somebody claiming >> that's that's
some people have said with no argument no basis absolutely erroneously
that I'm crashing out. What? How could you possibly argue that
I'm crashing out right now? Oh man. I don't know. That's a tough
one. It's a very tough one, man. Okay, dude. Somebody. Okay,
people need to the wellness check for Aiden is somebody needs
access to his socials. They need to block uh Bunk Synth
uh anybody else from that house, anybody else from that community.
Aiden cannot be allowed to interact with these people for up
to 6 months. Okay. 6 months detox from that community. It would
be cataclysmic. Okay. If Aiden is allowed to interact with that
community, fam. Yeah. Get them all out of here. Blocked them
all. Critical moment right now. Okay. Critical moment. He cannot
be talking to those people. It's absolutely [__]
over. If he could talk to those people. Okay. Okay. Hellbent.
That's just That just seems like below the belt. All right. You
already have you not stabbed this guy enough yet. You got to
you got to got to dishonor the body, too. He's already dead.
He's already dead. You put him in the ground. Okay. All right.
No, frankly. Okay.
He's not dead enough yet. Hellbent went from like, "No, leave
Aiden alone to Aiden. Kill Aiden now. Kill Aiden now." Very cool.
You love to see it. Okay, with that, I think we wrap up the 12
and 1 half hour stream. Straighter woke up and was like, "Hey,
do you want to talk about this?" I'm like, "No, I'm going to
bed. I'm going to bed. It's It's time for bed." Okay. Holy [__]
I'm going to bed.
That's what she Hold on. That is what she said. She was like,
"Oh, technically you're the one who's who's like leaving me hanging
now." I'm like, "Go
to bed, man." Okay. Yeah. W stream. Thank you guys for being
here. That was fun. Okay. I'll raid I'll raid Chud or something.
Ch's live. Raid Chud. Okay. Have a good night, everybody. Good
night. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye.